हे एवरीवन एंड गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल तो प्लीज
मुझे बता दीजिए सबसे पहले कि आई एम लाउड
एंड क्लियर
तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते
हैं ू टू फ मिनट का कि ताकि सभी लोग जवाइन
कर
ले क्लास
को ओके थैंक यू
आदम थैंक यू दीपांशु गुड इवनिंग दीपांशु
ओके थैंक यू
प्राग गुड इवनिंग
ओबिटो अगर प्रोनंसिएशन में कुछ प्रॉब्लम
है तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट क्योंकि आप
लोगों के नाम ओरिजिनल नाम तो होते नहीं
नॉर्मली थैंक यू कुमावत
आज भी अभी तक 39 ही है
कारण तो मुझे भी नहीं पता क्यों नहीं आना
चाहते लोग क्लास में इट्स ओके
सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं तो सेशन को
स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं कुछ आपको बता
देता हूं कि जो डीसी जेएसपी जो
प्रैक्टिकल्स है जो अभी हम पढ़ रहे हैं
फ्री में यह बिगनर टू इंटरमीडिएट है फिर
भी अगर ग्रुप में कोई ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स हैं
जिनको बिगनर टू इंटरमीडिएट आता है जिनको
थोड़ी सी और कांसेप्शनल नॉलेज नॉलेज
ज्यादा चाहिए थोड़ा डीप में जाना है और
प्रोजेक्ट के साथ काम करना है पाइथन सीखना
है नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी सीखना है और
ऑटोमेशन सीखना है तो एक एडवांस कोर्स जो
ऑलरेडी अनाउंसमेंट हो चुका है तो आप एक
बार उससे अगर आप डायरेक्टली आप इसको स्किप
करके वहां पर जा सकते हो डीसी एसपी को
जवाइन कर सकते हो जैसे मैं डेनिक्स को ओपन
करता हूं अपनी डेनिक्स अकेडमी तो वहां पर
आप जाके देख सकते हो उसका सिलेबस काफी
बड़ा है अभी मैं एक काम करता हूं नाउ दिस
इज अवर
यस यह डिप्लोमा इन साइबर सिक्योरिटी तो
सिक्स मंथ का डिप्लोमा ट्रेनिंग है जिसमें
आपने रिसोर्सेस या जहां पर आपने देखा होगा
कि उसका सिलेबस है काफी ह्यूज सिलेबस है
तो आप देख सकते हो ट्रेनिंग वाउचर को देख
सकते हो देखिए यह रहा तो इसमें बहुत कुछ
चीजें हैं तो हमारे सिलेबस में है लेकिन
हमारे सिलेबस में वोह सारे बेसिक कवर नहीं
किए जाएंगे जैसे कि कुछ जो फंडामेंटल्स रह
जाते हैं डीप फंडामेंटल्स जहां पर आप में
और ज्यादा डीप जाकर समझने की जरूरत होती
है ताकि इन फ्यूचर आपको खुद का टूल क्रिएट
करना हो या खुद की स्क्रिप्ट रन करनी हो
तो वह सारी चीजें आपको सीखनी होती हैं जो
आपके इन फ्यूचर में कभी भी आप ओससीपी देते
हो या कोई भी एग्जाम देना है या जहां पर
आपको ऑटोमेशन की जरूरत है अपना काम मतलब
कि थोड़ा सा और इजी वे में करना है तो वो
सारी चीजें आपको इस कोर्स के अंदर सिखाई
जाती है विद इन सिक्स मंथ जहां पर आपको
कोर्सेज का जो रिसोर्सेस देखोगे भर भर के
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी है आपका नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी एडवांस है और जैसे कि
आपके फिर पाइथन प्रोग्रामिंग ऑटोमेशंस है
उसमें प्रोजेक्ट के साथ आपको काम करवाया
जाता है देन आपके साथ करियर गाइडेंस है और
आपको इंटर्नशिप प्रोवाइड की जाती है तोय
सारी चीजें अपॉर्चुनिटी है आपके पास तो
अगर आपको इंटरमीडिएट टू सॉरी बेसिक टू
इंटरमीडिएट की नॉलेज है तो यू कैन गो एंड
जवाइन दिस कोर्स अभी भी इसकी क्ला स्टार्ट
होने में टाइम है तो आप
सिंपली फीस पे करके आप क्लासेस जवाइन कर
सकते हो अभी भी सीट अवेलेबल है तो
डायरेक्टली आपको इस कोर्स को जो लाइव है
वी जो लाइव ट्रेनिंग चल रही है यहां पर
डीसीएसपी जो प्रैक्टिकल है इस कोर्स को आप
स्किप करके इसको भी जवाइन कर सकते हो दिस
इज एक प्रोफेशनल कोर्स है तो इन फ्यूचर्स
में जो कॉमिनेशन रहेगा एक मास्टर
सर्टिफिकेशन जिसका एग्जाम आपको देके
क्लियर करने के बावजूद व सर्टिफिकेट
मिलेगा तो वो कॉमिनेशन होगा तो यू कैन गो
अगर आपको लगता है कि मेरे पास एनफ नॉलेज
है जो लाइव क्लास अटेंड नहीं करना चाहते
या रिकॉर्डिंग भी नहीं देखते जिनको लगता
कि मेरे पास एनफ नॉलेज है मुझे एडवांस
सीखना है लेकिन जो लाइव चल रही है
youtube1 डिप्लोमा ट्रेनिंग है इसको जवाइन
कर सकते
हो
[संगीत]
तो उसके बाद स्टार्ट करते हैं हम अपने फिर
अपने कोर्स को कंटिन्यू करते हैं
थोड़ा सा प्रैक्टिकल थोड़ा सा
थोरेट्स
का इंतजार था आप लोगों को एन मैप के बारे
में जानने
का वह इंतजार खत्म होने वाला आपका और एन
मैप के बारे में हम काफी अच्छे से डिटेल
इंफॉर्मेशन लेंगे इन अपकमिंग क्लासेस में
अभी भी और अपकमिंग क्लासेस में दिस इ नॉट
ओनली वन वीडियो जहां पर आपको एन मैप के
बारे में सब कुछ डिटेल में बता दिया जाएगा
कुछ और भी वीडियोस में जाके एन मैप खत्म
हो मे बी टू थ वीडियोस के अंदर जाकर आपका
जो एन मैप है कंप्लीट एन मैप आपका खत्म
होगा तो उससे पहले हम फिर से कुछ बेसिक
रिक्वायरमेंट है उसको फुलफिल करेंगे बिफोर
एन मैप देन हम एन मैप के बारे में हंट
करेंगे सॉरी एन मैप की हेल्प से हम
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करेंगे तो मे भी दे
ओनली टोटल 48 स्टूडेंट अभी भी 50 भी नहीं
हुए हैं तो आई कान से
तो अभी चलते हैं ना दिस योर डाउट बोर्ड तो
ओनली एक ही डाउट था जो लास्ट क्लास में
हमने डिस्कस कर लिया था और अभी मैंने
रिलेटेड टू प्रीवियस डे सिक्स मतलब सिक्सथ
क्लास का कोई भी डाउट आपको नहीं आया है तो
मतलब आपने कोई भी डाउट नहीं पूछा था आपका
जो डाउट बोर्ड है वो नील है तो आप इसका
मतलब दो ही कारण है या तो आपको सब कुछ समझ
में आ गया या बिल्कुल आपको बिल्कुल ही
क्लियर हो गया ऊपर से चला गया मतलब कोई
मतलब नहीं आपको तो दो ही रीजन होते हैं
डाउट ना आने के या तो आपको सब कुछ समझ में
आ गया या बिल्कुल ही ऊपर से चला गया जहां
पर आपके डाउट कभी आते ही नहीं तो दज आर द
टू रीजन तो डाउट बोर्ड आपका अभी भी ल है
तो मैं चाहता हूं कि ज्यादा से ज्यादा
डाउट्स आपको पूछने चाहिए अपनी क्लासेस में
और प्रोसेस आपको पता है कि डाउट कैसे
पूछते हैं कि आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
जैसे ही यह वीडियो खत्म हो जाए जैसे ये
लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग कंप्लीट हो जाएगी लाइव
स्ट्रीमिंग कंप्लीट होने के बाद जो वीडियो
है रिकॉर्ड अवेलेबल होता है
youtube2 टू आवर पेन टेस्ट जर्नी थी जहां
पर मैंने बताया था आपको पै क्या होता है
उसके बाद मैंने बताया था आपको आईपी पैकेज
पैकेट की स्ट्रक्चर आपको मैंने बताया था
एक फॉर्मेट दिखाया था जिसके अंदर क्याक
इंफॉर्मेशन होती है सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस
होता है सोर्स डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस होता है
टीटीएल वैल्यू होती है उसके और भी बहुत
सारी चीजें होती है इस पैकेट के अंदर इवन
मैंने आपको वायर शर्क प भी शो करके दिखाया
था तो अभी टर्न आता है आपका ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर का तो सबको पता है कि सिग्निफिकेंट
क्या है इस ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का परपज क्या
है किस पर्पस से इसको यूज किया जाता है
फिर भी भी मैं आपको बता देता हूं इट प्लेज
ए क्रुशल रोल इन फैसिलिटेटिंग
कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन टू डिवाइसेज अक्रॉस ए
नेटवर्क मे बी कम्युनिकेशन स्पेलिंग रंग
हो गई है तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट तो जब दो
डिवाइसेज एक दूसरे के साथ कम्युनिकेशन
करते हैं नेटवर्क के ऊपर तो उसके बीच में
एक काफी इंपोर्टेंट रोल प्ले करता है इट
इंश्योर रिलायबल एंड टू एंड कम्युनिकेशन
हैंडलिंग टास्क सच एज एरर डिटेक्शन फ्लो
कंट्रोल एंड सेगमेंटेशन ऑफ डाटा इन टू
स्मल यूनिट आप सबको पहले से ही पता है
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पर क्या-क्या होता है इट
इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर प्रोवाइड ऑर्डर
डिलीवरी ऑफ डाटा बिटवीन टू डिवाइस ऑन ए
नेटवर्क डेफिनेटली यू नो तो दे आर टू
इंपोर्टेंट प्रोटोकॉल्स ऑपरेट ऑन द
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर एंड व्हाट आर दज
प्रोटोकॉल्स टीसीपी एंड यूडीपी ट्रांसमिशन
कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल और यूजर डेटा गाम
प्रोटोकॉल दीज प्रोटोकॉल्स आर यूज टू अचीव
डिफरेंट गोल्स दे आर यूटिलाइज और
इंप्लीमेंटेड इन स्पेसिफिक एरियाज वेयर
देर फंक्शन इ रिक्वायर्ड और प्रेफर्ड अब
टीसीपी और यूडीपी इन दोनों प्रोटोकॉल
का जो एप्लीकेशन की जो रिक्वायरमेंट है
उसके हिसाब से इनको यूज किया जाता है ओके
तो नाउ अभी टीसीपी के बारे में थोड़ी सी
इंफॉर्मेशन लेंगे और यूडीपी के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन लेंगे देन उसके बाद हम अपना जो
मेन टॉपिक है होस्ट डिस्कवरी उसके ऊपर
स्विच करेंगे ना टीसी
ट्रांसमिशन कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल टीसीपी इज
वन ऑफ द मेन प्रोटोकॉल दैट ऑपरेट्स एट द
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर ऑफ द ओएआई
मॉडल इट इज ए कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड एंड
रिलायबल प्रोटोकॉल दैट प्रोवाइड्स ए
डिपेंडेबल एंड ऑर्डर डिलीवरी ऑफ डाटा
बिटवीन डिवाइसेज ओवर ए नेटवर्क एक कनेक्शन
ओरिएंटेड प्रोटोकॉल है मतलब कम्युनिकेशन
करने से पहले यह एक कनेक्शन
इस्टैब्लिशमेंट करता है आपका टीसीपी और
रिलायबल प्रोटोकॉल है क्योंकि डाटा
डिलीवरी की गारंटी देता है उसको एक ऑर्डर
में डाटा को भेजता है इट इंश्योर दैट डाटा
इज सेंड फ्रॉम वन एप्लीकेशन ऑन ए डिवाइस
इज रिसीवड एक्युरेटली एंड इन द करेक्ट
ऑर्डर बाय अनदर एप्लीकेशन ऑन ए डिफरेंट
डिवाइसेज सारी की सारी लाइने सेल्फ
एक्सप्लेनेटरी है शायद मुझे एक्सप्लेन
करने की जरूरत नहीं है एंड वई इट इज
प्रेफर्ड प्रोटोकॉल फॉर इंप्लीमेंटिंग अदर
प्रोटोकॉल्स देखिए
बिकॉज़ इट एस्टेब्लिश ए कनेक्शन बिटवीन द
सेंडर एंड द रिसीवर बिफोर सेंडिंग एनी
डाटा इज एक्सचेंज कोई भी डाटा एक्सचेंज
करने से पहले यह क्या करता है कनेक्शन
एस्टेब्लिश करता है वेरीफाई कर मतलब
कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश करता है ओके इन ऑर्डर
टू सेट अप और एस्टेब्लिश ए टीसीबी कनेक्शन
देयर नीड टू बी एन ऑथेंटिकेशन और हैंड शेक
वेयर देयर इज एक्नॉलेजमेंट बाय बोथ द
क्लांट एंड द सर्वर मतलब क्या है कि इस
कनेक्शन को एस्टेब्लिश करने के लिए या तो
एक ऑथेंटिकेशन बोल सकते हो या एक हैंड शेक
हाथ मिलाया जाता है क्लाइंट और सर्वर के
द्वारा दो
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट
डाटा ट्रांसफर ये एक वर्चुअल सर्किट होता
है एक वर्चुअल कनेक्शन होता है जो इंश्योर
करता है कि आपके रिलायबल डाटा आपका
रिलायबल ट्रांसफर हो जाए ट्रांसफर हो जाए
और
ऑर्डर्स पी गारंटी रिलायबल डिलीवरी ऑफ
डाटा इट इज अचीव्ड बाय ए मैकेनिज्म सच एज
एक्नॉलेजमेंट्स एंड रिट्रांसमिशन ऑफ लॉस्ट
और करप्टेड पैकेट्स इफ ए सेगमेंट ऑफ डाटा
इज नॉट एक्नॉलेज इट ऑटोमेटिक रिसेंड द
सेगमेंट्स अभी जो टीसीपी है आपको यह
गारंटी करता है गारंटी देता है कि जो आपका
डाटा है वह उसको 100% डिलीवर किया जाएगा
कैसे एक्नॉलेजमेंट का यूज़ करके जितना
डाटा ट्रांसफर करता है उसका एक्नॉलेजमेंट
लेता है जैसे एक्नॉलेज मिलता है उसको
ओके रिसीवर ने उसको एक्नॉलेजमेंट दिया कि
ओके इतना डाटा मेरे को मिल गया तब उसके
बाद कंटिन्यू ट्रांसमिशन चलता रहता अगर
किसी भी डाटा का उसको एक्नॉलेजमेंट नहीं
मिलता तो उस डाटा को क्या करता वो समझता
कि या तो करप्ट हो गया लस्ट हो गया उसको
क्या करता है फिर रिट्रांसमिट करता है
सेंडर रिसीवर के पास ओके इट इंशोर ट डाटा
इ डिलीवर्ड इन द करेक्ट ऑर्डर इफ द
सेगमेंट ऑफ डाटा अराइव आउट ऑफ ऑर्डर
टीसीपी रीऑर्डर देम बिफोर पासिंग टू द
हाईयर लेयर एप्लीकेशन अभी क्या होता जो
टीसीपी है वो जब रि के पास डाटा को सेंड
करता है तो डायरेक्टली वह रिसीवर को हैंड
ना करके क्या करता है अपने बफर में उसको
क्या करता है स्टोर करता है बफर में पूरा
रिअसेंबल करके अरेंज करके तब जाकर वह अपर
लेयर को डाटा को प्रोवाइड करता है ओके बफर
को पता होगा पार्ट ऑफ मेमोरी होती है जहां
पर डाटा को स्टोर किया जाता
है
ना अभी बात करते हैं टीसीपी हेडर कि जब
आईपी हेडर के बारे में मैंने पढ़ा था उसी
प्रकार से एक टीसीपी हेडर होता है ओके
क्योंकि अब मैंने बताया था कि पैकेट जब
ट्रेवल करता है तो पैकेट में दो चीजें
होती है एक तो हेडर होता है एक डाटा होता
है जो पेलोड होता है तो अभी मैं हेडर की
बात करता हूं कि हेडर में क्याक
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलती है टीसीपी
हेडर के अंदर सोर्स पोर्ट डेस्टिनेशन
पोर्ट सीक्वेंस नंबर एक्नॉलेजमेंट नंबर
हेडर लेंथ रिजर्व बिट अर्जेंट
एक्नॉलेजमेंट पुश रिसेट सिं फिन फिनिश
विंडो साइज चेक सम अर्जेंट पॉइंटर ये सारी
चीजें क्या होती है मैं आपको सामने
एक्सप्लेन कर देता हूं देखिए अभी हम चलते
हैं चैट जीपीटी पर चैट जीपीटी ने इसको
अच्छे से एक्सप्लेन किया है सोर्स पोर्ट
में क्या है कि जिस पोर्ट से डाटा
आपका ट्रेवल कर रहा है जिस पोर्ट से आपके
पैकेट को भेजा गया है उसका एड्रेस मिलता
है यहां पर किसके अंदर सोर्स पोर्ट के
अंदर डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट कि किस पोर्ट पर ये
डाटा जाएगा फॉर एग्जांपल पोर्ट 80 443
पोर्ट 22 एटस एटस ओके या पोर्ट 8080 इस
तरीके से देन उसके बाद सीक्वेंस नंबर होता
है सीक्वेंस नंबर क्या करता है दिस फील्ड
स्पेसिफाई द सीक्वेंस नंबर ऑफ द फर्स्ट
बाइट ऑफ डाटा इन द सेगमेंट इट इज यूज टू
रिअसेंबल द डाटा करेक्टली एट द रिसीविंग
एंड इंश्योर दैट पैकेट्स आर प्रोसीड इन
करेक्ट ऑर्डर बेसिकली क्या है सीक्वेंस
नंबर क्या करता है कि आपका पैकेट है उसको
सही ऑर्डर से ट्रांसफर हुआ या नहीं हुआ
उसको मेक शर करने में काम आता है क्योंकि
सीक्वेंस नंबर काफी हेल्पफुल होता है डाटा
को रि असेंबल करते वक्त एक्नॉलेजमेंट नंबर
होता है जब क्या करते हो आप एक जब डाटा
ट्रांसफर हुआ डाटा ट्रांसफर होते हुए उसका
एक सीक्वेंस नंबर होता है तो उसी का
एक्नॉलेजमेंट बताया जाता कि ओके स 100
सीक्वेंस नंबर का डाटा मेरे को सक्सेसफुली
रिसीव हो गया है तो वो एक्नॉलेजमेंट नंबर
में पता चलता है उसको एक बढ़ा के बता देता
है नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं हम डाटा
ऑफसेट की अभी डटा ऑफसेट की बात करते हैं
यह
रहा ओके यह
रहा डाटा ऑफसेट आल्सो नोन एज हेडर लेंथ
दिस फीड स्पेसिफाई द साइज ऑफ द टीसीपी
हेडर इन 32 बिट्स इट टेल्स वे द डेटा
पोर्शन ऑफ द पैकेट बिगिंस दिस इज
इंपोर्टेंट बिकॉज टीसीपी हेडर कैन वेरी इन
साइज डिपेंड्स ऑन द ऑप्शन सेट ओके तो जो
यह लेंथ जो आपको क्या हेडर लेंथ है जो फोर
बिट्स की आपको यह बताता है कि जो टीसीपी
हेडर है डाटा को छोड़ के उसका साइज क्या
है ओके रिजर्व बिट अब रिजर्व बिट में क्या
किया रिजर्व कर दी गई है कि फर्द कहीं पर
कुछ भी हेडर में इंफॉर्मेशन ऐड करने के
लिए ये रिजर्व बिट है देन उसके बाद
फ्लैग्स आते हैं टीसीबी फ्लैग्स ओके
अर्जेंट एक्नॉलेजमेंट फ्लैग पुश फ्लैग
आरएसटीबी फ्लैग और फिन फ्लैग ओके तो इनका
आपको ऑटोमेटिक ली भी पता चल जाए मैं जैसे
थोड़ा सा आगे जाऊंगा ए मैप के बारे में
बताऊंगा थोड़ा सा आपको ब्रीफ इंट्रोडक्शन
चाहिए तो यह रहा देखो
एकन अमेंट फीड इज वैलिड पुश फ्लैग का मतलब
पुश मतलब सेल्फ एक्स सिन फ्लैग फिन फ्लैग
ये कैसे काम करते हैं आई विल एक्सप्लेन
डोंट वरी अब इसमें आपको बताऊंगा तो यू आर
नॉट एबल टू
अंडरस्टैंड नाउ उसके बाद बात करते हैं
विंडोज साइज विंडोज साइज क्या होता है
देखिए आपको अगर पता होगा कि जो आपका
टीसीपी है टीसीपी फ्लो कंट्रोल भी करता है
टीसीपी क्या करता है फ्लो कंट्रोल भी करता
है और एरर डिटेक्शन भी करता है तो फ्लो
कंट्रोल कैसे करता है जब भी सेंडर और
रिसीवर जब भी क्या करते हैं तो टीसी भी
कनेक्शन एब्लिश करते हैं तो व क्या करते
हैं आपस में चेक करते हैं कि स्पीड कितना
स्पोर्ट मतलब कि जो रिसीवर है वह कितना
डाटा रिसीव कर सकता है एक साथ और उसी
प्रकार से सेंडर सेंडर भी बताता कि मैं
ओके मैं इतना तो व अपने बीच में एक सेटअप
करते हैं जिसको हम बोलते हैं टीसीपी
विंडोइंग जिसको हम क्या बोलते हैं टीसीपी
विंडोइंग फॉर एग्जांपल वो नेगोशिएट करते
हैं एक साइज के ऊपर फॉर एग्जांपल मैं आपको
एग्जांपल दिखाता हूं टीसीपी विंडोइंग
का यह रहा
एक्सप्लेन य र इमेज से मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा टीसीपी विंडोइंग
ये
रहा सेव इमेज डाउनलोड एंड देन आई विल
ओपन ये रहा मे बी नॉट क्लियर
इमेज आपको दिख जाएगा ये रहा अगर यहां पर
देखोगे आप कोने में कि यह क्लाइंट है यह
वेब सर्वर है तो जब ये कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश
कर रहे थे तो वहां पर क्या है दोनों क्या
करते हैं नेगोशिएट करते हैं कि मैं इतना
ही डाटा क्या कर सकता हूं
रिसीव कर सकता हूं एक साइज स्टब इतने बाइट
का डाटा मैं क्या कर सकता हूं रिसीव
करूंगा तो यहां पर क्या फॉर एग्जांपल दे
एग्री 5000 बाइट तो क्या होगा कि जब जो
क्लाइंट है और क्लाइंट क्या करेगा डाटा
सेंड करेगा तो वेब सर्स के बदले में क्या
करेगा डाटा जब कनेक्शन बबलिश हो जाएगा तो
क्या करेगा डाटा सेंड करेगा तो य क्या
करेंगे नंबर बाइट 1000 2000 3000 जैसे
5000 हो जाएगा तब आपका क्या करेगा क्लाइंट
उस परे एक्नॉलेजमेंट देगा अगर इन्हीं के
बीच में कहीं पर आपका पैकेट लॉस हो गया तो
क्या होगा कि एक् 5001 की बजाय आपको क्या
देखने को मिलेगा जो लॉस नंबर जिस जहां से
फॉर एग्जांपल 2000 तक का ही आपको बाइट का
डाटा आपको मिला तो क्या होगा 2001 आपको
एक्नॉलेजमेंट नंबर मिलेगा क्लाइंट की साइड
से ओके रदर देन 5001
क्योंकि उसके पास जो डाटा आया 2000 तक का
ही आया तो उसके बाद क्या करेगा आपका जो
सीपी है उसको फिर से 2001 से लेकर
कंटिन्यू रिट्रांसमिट करेगा इस तरीके से
क्या करर एक तो फ्लो कंट्रोल हो जाता है
आपका डटा का साथ में एरर कंट्रोल भी हो
जाता है तो मे भी एवरीवन गट अंडरस्टूड
एवरीवन गट क्लियर टीसीपी विंडोइंग सिस्टम
कि अपने आप नेगोशिएट करता कि कितने साइज
का मैं डाटा क्या कर सकता हूं रिसीव कर
सकता हूं क्लाइंट बताता है
नाउ ओके देन उसके बाद चेक सम आपको पता है
अर्जेंट पॉइंटर क्या करता है कि अगर आपका
फ्लैग अर्जेंट सेट है मतलब कि प्रायोरिटी
रखता है आपके डाटा की कि ओके यह जो पैकेट
है यह ऑन प्रायोरिटी पैकेट है और इतने
सीक्वेंस नंबर तक का क्या है की पैकेट ऑन
प्रायोरिटी है तो उस वो यहां पर क्या करता
है अर्जेंट पॉइंटर के अंदर देखने को
मिलेगा आपको प्रजेंट पॉइंटर के अंदर देखने
को मिलेगा जिससे क्या होगी डाटा की आपकी
प्रा रहेगी उसी प्रायोरिटी पर आपका डाटा
डिलीवर किया जाएगा हाई प्रायोरिटी है तो
सबसे पहले उसको डिलीवर किया जाएगा ऑ
ऑप्शनल में क्या होता है आप ऑप्शनल दिस
फीड इज ऑप्शनल एंड कैन वेरी इन लेंथ इट
अलाउ फॉर एडिशनल फीचर सच एज मैक्सिमम
सेगमेंट साइज विंडो स्केल फैक्टर टाइम
स्टैंप या अदर मतलब और कोई अगर पैकेट के
अंदर अदर इंफॉर्मेशन आप ऐड करना चाहते तो
आप ऑप्शन फील्ड के अंदर रखोगे देन उसके
बाद आपका जो डटा है वो आपका एक्चुअल डाटा
होता है तो दिस इज द दिस इज यो और
टीसीसीपी हैडर जो आपको देखने का मिलता है
जब भी आपका हैंड सेक कंप्लीट होता है उस
टाइम पर जो डेटा पैकेट्स होते हैं तो
टीसीपी हेडर में इस तरह की इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको देखने को मिलती है जब वायक साग से आप
एनालाइज करोगे तो सोर्स पोर्ट डेस्टिनेशन
पोर्ट सीक्वेंस नंबर एक्नॉलेजमेंट नंबर
हेडर लेंथ उसके बाद टीसीपी फ्लैग्स विंडो
विंडो साइज चेक्सम अर्जेंट पॉइंटर सेट नोट
सेट डिपेंड्स और ऑप्शंस अगर अवेलेबल है तो
यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको टीसीपी हेडर के
अंदर देखने को मिलेगी एवरीवन गट क्लियर
तो नेक्स्ट चले
ओके अभी यूडीपी के बारे में बात करते हैं
यूडीपी क्या होता है यूजर डेटा गाम
प्रोटोकॉल यूडीपी इज ए कनेक्शन लेस एंड
लाइट वेट ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर प्रोटोकॉल यह
क्या है कनेक्शन लेस यूडीपी डज नॉट एब्लिश
ए कनेक्शन बिफोर सेंडिंग डाटा डाटा को
सेंड करने से पहले यूडीपी किसी भी प्रकार
का कोई भी कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश नहीं करता
इट डज नॉट प्रोवाइड द सेम लेवल ऑफ
रिलायबिलिटी
एंड ऑर्डरिंग गारंटी इंस्टेड इट फोकस ऑन
सिंपलीसिटी एंड एफिशिएंसी मेक सूटेबल फॉर
सर्टेन टाइप्स ऑफ
एप्लीकेशन यूडीपी इज यूज फॉर रियल टाइम
एप्लीकेशंस वेयर लो लेटेंसी इ क्रुशल सच
एज ऑडियो एंड वीडियो स्ट्रीमिंग ऑनलाइन
गेमिंग एंड वीओ आईपी
कम्युनिकेशन बेसिकली क्या है यूडीपी
कनेक्शन लेस प्रोटोकॉल है आपके डाटा की
कोई गारंटी नहीं देता साथ के साथ आपको
डाटा की कोई एक्नॉलेजमेंट दे ने को नहीं
मिलेगी एक तो क्या है कि कोई भी कनेक्शन
क्रिएट नहीं करता डाटा को सेंड करने से
पहले डायरेक्टली डाटा को भेज देता है और
आपके डाटा की कोई गारंटी नहीं है कि व
आपको ट्रांसपोर्ट होगा या नहीं होगा वो
डाटा को लेकर जरूर जाएगा लेकिन अगर बीच
में डाटा पैकेट करप्ट हो ग या लॉस हो गए
तो वह रिट्रांसमिशन भी नहीं करेगा उसकी
कोई गारंटी नहीं है डाटा को पहुंचाने की
बस व कैरी करेगा अगर पहुंच गया तो ठीक है
अग बीच में अगर करप्ट हो गया तो हो गया
उसके बाद क्या है कि बेसिकली जो यूडीपी है
यह फास्ट है देन टीसीपी टीसीपी से ज्यादा
फास्ट काम करता है तो इसलिए रियल टाइम
एप्लीकेशन के लिए इसको यूज किया जाता है
खास कर की ऑडियो वीडियो स्ट्रीमिंग ऑनलाइन
गेमिंग या वब कम्युनिकेशन के लिए इट इज अ
स्टेटलेस्विजेट
पैकेट मतलब एक दूसरे पैकेट पर क्या
इंडिपेंडेंट करते हैं कोई भी पैकेट एक
दूसरे पैकेट पर डिपेंड नहीं करता तो दिस
इज द फंक्शन ऑफ यूडीपी टीसीपी गारंटी लेता
है डाटा को भेजने की लेकिन यूडीपी कोई भी
गारंटी नहीं लेता ओके डाटा को रिलायबल
ट्रांसफर करने की ओके दिस इज द डिफरेंस
बिटवीन टीसीपी एंड
यूडीपी नाउ मे बी एवरीवन गट क्लियर व्हाट
इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन टीसीपी एंड यूडीपी
टीसीपी क्या करता है कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड
प्रोटोकॉल है कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश करता है
यूडीपी कनेक्शन लेस है कोई भी कनेक्शन
नहीं बनाता टीसीपी गारंटी लेता है डाटा की
लेकिन यूडीपी कोई भी गारंटी नहीं लेता
रिलायबिलिटी की ऊपर से टीसीपी क्या करता
है अगर डाटा पैकेट लॉस हो गए तो
रिट्रांसमिशन करेगा लेकिन यूडीपी
रिट्रांसमिशन नहीं करेगा ओके दज इज द मेन
पॉइंट्स
व्हाट अबाउट यूडीपी
लाइट यूडीपी लाइट का यूडीपी एक लाइट वेट
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर बस एक आपको एक्सप्लेन
करने के लिए इंगलिश में एक्सप्लेन करने के
लिए कुछ इसकी जो वर्डियन करने की कनेक्शन
लाइट वेट ओके यह है बाकी यूडीपी का काम
वही है टीसीपी यूडीपी डिफरेंस वही है कि
एक तो कोई भी कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश नहीं
किया जाता यूडीपी के केस में टीसीपी के
बेस में कनेक्शन एब्लिश हो गया इसलिए डाटा
की गारंटी है लेकिन यहां पर डाटा की
पहुंचने की कोई भी गारंटी नहीं है
रिलायबिलिटी कम है यहां पर हां टीसीपी
स्लो है यूडीपी फास्ट है
ओके बेसिकली आपने डीएनएस देख होगा वो भी
यूडीपी पर काम करता है डीएचसीपी हो गया
बेसिकली आपके जो स्ट्रीमिंग होती है जो
हमारी जो अभी भी स्ट्रीमिंग हो रही है तो
इसमें तो क्या कि दोनों प्रोटोकॉल्स काम
कर रहे हैं टीसीपी प्लस यूडीपी ओके
क्योंकि यूडीपी का काम है आपकी स्ट्रीमिंग
को हैंडल करना एफिशिएंसी को देखना बार-बार
लेकिन टीसीपी जो हमारी चैट चल रही है चैट
सेक्शन अभी हम चैट में बातें कर रहे हैं
तो यह टीसीपी का काम है
चलो अभी नेक्स्ट चलते हैं एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग का जो होस्ट डिस्कवरी
फेस है अभी य नेटवर्किंग की क्लास नहीं है
क्योंकि हम इस पर ज्यादा बहस नहीं करेंगे
कि बस बेसिक डिफरेंस आपको बताना था अगर
जिसको ज्यादा डीप में नॉलेज चाहिए तो या
तो जवाइन करो नेक्स्ट एडवांस कोर्स या
दूसरा ऑप्शन आपके पास है सेल्फ रिसर्च
कीजिए मैंने जितना आपके लिए रिक्वायरमेंट
है इस कोर्स के लिए उतनी डिटेल्स मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं मैं आपके सवाल से छुप नहीं
रहे हूं आपको लग रहा है कि सर आप मेरे
सवाल का जो जवाब नहीं दे रहे हो क्योंकि
हमें कोर्स को भी कंप्लीट करना है लेकिन
जितनी रिक्वायरमेंट है उतनी रिक्वायरमेंट
आपकी फुलफिल करूंगा मैं 100% फुलफिल
करूंगा ओके फिर भी अगर आपका कोई डाउट है
तो यू कैन आस्क इन द कमेंट सेक्शन आई विल
डेफिनेटली आंसर यू
अभी बात करते हैं नेटवर्क मैपिंग सबसे
पहले हम बात करते हैं नेटवर्क मैपिंग अभ
यह क्या चीज होती है मैंने आपको बताया था
स्टार्टिंग में ही कि हम नेटवर्किंग फंड
जो फंडामेंटल्स उनको क्लियर करेंगे देन
उसके बाद हम नेटवर्क
मैपिंग नाउ वी हैव द नॉलेज ऑफ फंडामेंटल्स
ऑफ नेटवर्किंग स्पेशली नेटवर्क एंड
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर हमारे पास इसकी नॉलेज है
एवरीवन एग्री इन दिस सेक्शन वी आर गोइंग
टू बी एक्सप्लोरिंग द प्रोसेस ऑफ होस्ट
डिस्कवरी अभी इस सेक्शन में हम क्या
करेंगे कि जो होस्ट डिस्कवरी की जो
प्रोसेस है कैसे हम होस्ट डिस्कवर करते
हैं उसके
ऊपर डिटेल में सीखेंगे होस्ट डिस्कवरी इज
द पार्ट ऑफ नेटवर्क
मैपिंग यह क्या है नेटवर्क मैपिंग का एक
पार्ट है विद इन द नेटवर्क मैपिंग वी हैव
ए प्लेंटी ऑफ टेक्निक्स और टास्क दैट आर
प्रेफर्ड एंड वन ऑफ देम इज होस्ट डिस्कवरी
नेटवर्क मैपिंग करने के लिए बहुत सारे
टेक्निक्स होती हैं बहुत सारे टास्क है
जिनके थ्रू हम क्या कर सकते हैं नेटवर्क
मैपिंग कर सकते हैं जिनमें से एक जो
हिस्सा है वह आपका क्या है हॉट होस्ट
डिस्कवरी सॉरी सॉरी फॉर रॉन्ग प्रोनाउंस
एंड इट इज वेरी इंपोर्टेंट टू अंडरस्टैंड
व्हाट नेटवर्क मैपिंग इज ऑल अबाउट
स्पेसिफिकली विद रिगार्ड्स टू एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग इसलिए हमारे लिए
नेटवर्क मैपिंग के बारे में जानना काफी
जरूरी है खास कर कि इन केस ऑफ एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में नेटवर्क मैपिंग का क्या रोल
है आफ्टर कलेक्टिंग इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट ए
टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ड्यूरिंग द पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्टेज ए पेंटेस्टर मूव
ऑन टू एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग फेज
व्हिच इवॉल्व डिस्कवरिंग होटस ऑन ए
नेटवर्क परफॉर्मिंग पोर्ट स्कैनिंग एंड
एनम मेशन अभी क्या होता है कि जब आपने एक
बार पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर लिया
नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा क्या होता है एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग जिसमें हम यह पता करते
हैं कौन-कौन से होस्ट होस्ट का मतलब क्या
कौन से पीसीज हैं कौन से सर्वर्स हैं कौन
से डिवाइसेज हैं नेटवर्क के ऊपर जो क्या
है एक्टिव है अगर और उसके बाद अगर हमें
उनकी लिस्ट मिल जाती है उनके ऊपर हम क्या
करते हैं फिर पोर्ट स्कैनिंग परफॉर्म करते
हैं और फर्द एन्यूमरेशन करते हैं उनके ऊपर
सर्विसेस फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते
हैं कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस एक्टिव होस्ट के
ऊपर रन कर रही हैं उसके बाद फर्द
एक्सप्लोइटेशन पार्ट अप्लाई करते हैं या
वल्नरेबल असेसमेंट करते हैं एज वी नो एवरी
होस्ट इज कनेक्टेड टू द इंटरनल और
प्राइवेट नेटवर्क एंड मस्ट हैव यूनिक आईपी
एड्रेस दैट यूनिकल
आइडेंटिफिकेशन करता है जो इंटरनेट का यूज
करता है वो या तो
इंटरनली या किसी प्राइवेट नेटवर्क के
द्वारा क्या है कनेक्टेड है और वह उसका एक
यूनिक आइडेंटिटी है जिसको हम क्या बोलते
हैं आईपी एड्रेस इन सर्टेन केसेस दिस आईपी
एड्रेस कुड बी स्टेटिक और डायनेमिक अब जो
य आईपी एड्रेस है यह स्टेटिक भी हो सकता
है या ड डायनेमिक भी हो सकता
है नाउ नाउ अवर मेन ऑब्जेक्टिव इ फोकस ऑन
द प्रोसेस ऑफ
आइडेंटिफिकेशन टली एक्टिव देखिए कि जो मेन
ऑब्जेक्टिव
हमारा अभी इस कोर्स का जो एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग का कि यह पता करना कि
कितने होस्ट ऑनलाइन है और करेंटली एक्टिव
है
ओके हाउ कैन पन टेस्टर डिटरमाइंड वि व्ट
होस्ट विदन एन इन स्कोप नेटवर्क आर ऑनलाइन
व्ट पोर्ट्स आर ओपन ऑन द एक्टिव होस्ट और
व्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आर रनिंग ऑन द एक्टिव
होस्ट अभी एक सवाल है कि सर ए पन टेस्टर
मैं कैसे पता करूंगा कि जो मेरा इन स्कोप
नेटवर्क है उसके अंदर कौन से होस्ट ऑनलाइन
है उनके ऊपर कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स एक्टिव है
ओके रनिंग है और कौन-कौन सी सर्विस उनके
ऊपर रन कर रही है और कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम उसके ऊपर रन कर रहा होगा यह सारी
चीजें तो इसका हम यह इंफॉर्मेशन सारी की
सारी हम क्या कर सकते हैं थ्रो नेटवर्क
मैपिंग नाउ नेटवर्क मैपिंग होती क्या है
इसके बारे में जानते हैं नेटवर्क मैपिंग
रेफर टू द प्रोसेस ऑफ डिस्कवरिंग एंड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एंड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
मैपिंग का यूज करते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करने के लिए एक नेटवर्क लेआउट के
बारे में उसकी आर्किटेक्चर जानने के लिए
और उसके अंदर एंट्री पॉइंट फाइंड आउट करने
के लिए फर्द एक्सप्लोइटेशन परफॉर्म करने
के लिए फॉर एग्जांपल एज ए पेन टेस्टर
लेट्स से यू वर्क फॉर ए कंपनी एंड कंपनी
सेज दैट यू आर अलाउड टू पेन टेस्ट ए
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन और आईपी
रेंज अभी मैं एग्जांपल लूं तो एक कंपनी है
कंपनी ने आपको बोला कि ओके आपको एज ए
पेंटेस्टर हायर किया गया है आपको अलाउड है
कि यह जो पर्टिकुलर डोमेन है यह जो
पर्टिकुलर आईपी रेंज है आप इस परे पेन
टेस्ट करके मुझे एक रिपोर्ट सबमिट करो तो
इफ इट इज ब्लैक बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग अगर यह
ब्लैक बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग है देन कंपनी विल
नॉट टोल्ड एनीथिंग अबाउट द नेटवर्क विद
रिगार्ड्स टू हाउ मेनी सिस्टम्स आर विद इन
द नेटवर्क और सबनेट अगर आप आपको बोला गया
कि आपको ब्लैक बॉक्स पेन टेस्टिंग करनी है
जो कि हमारे कोर्स हमारा कोर्स है तो
कंपनी इस इंफॉर्मेशन के अलावा डोमेन और
आईपी रेंज के अलावा आपको कोई भी अदर
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड नहीं करेगी पेन
टेस्टिंग परफॉर्म करने के लिए ओके सो योर
फर्स्ट ऑर्डर ऑफ बिजनेस इज टू ट्राई एंड
मैप आउट व्हाट होस्ट आर ऑनलाइन विद इन दैट
पर्टिकुलर आईपी रेंज एंड सेकंड ट्राई टू
बिल्ड इवन ए वेरी बेसिक नेटवर्क टोपोलॉजी
यू आर डीलिंग विद बेसिकली सबसे पहला आपका
काम क्या रहेगा कि यह पता करना इस पूरे
आईपी रेंज के अंदर पूरे सबनेट के अंदर या
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन के अंदर कौन-कौन से होस्ट
ऑनलाइन हैं दूसरा काम क्या है अब उन होस्ट
की इंफॉर्मेशन के बाद बेस पर आधार पर आप
क्या करोगे बेसिक आईडिया लगाओगी ओके इस
टाइप की नेटवर्क टोपोलॉजी यहां पर यूज हो
सकती है वन है लन है या इस तरह की नेट
नेटवर्क टोपोलॉजी को यूज कर सकते हैं इस
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के अंदर आपको एक
एस्टिमेशन लगाना है नाउ व्हाई वी नीड टू
मैप ए नेटवर्क अब मुझे नेटवर्क को मैप
करने की क्यों जरूरत है वी नीड ए वे टू
मैप आउट एन अननोन नेटवर्क इनटू समथिंग मोर
यूजफुल अब जब हमारे पास एक आईपी एड्रेस
मिलता है एक डोमेन मिलता है तो हमारे पास
वोह अननोन नेटवर्क होता है तो मेरा क्या
काम सबसे पहले उसको कुछ यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन
में कन्वर्ट करना कुछ ऐसी चीज जिसको मैं
क्या कर सकूं फर्द पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
में यूज कर सकूं वी डोंट नो एनीथिंग अबाउट
द टारगेट नेटवर्क द ऑब्जेक्टिव इज टू
डेवलप ए पिक्चर ऑफ द नेटवर्क आर्किटेक्चर
एंड द सिस्टम दैट मेक अप द नेटवर्क एज ए
होल हम सफ एक ऐसी पिक्चर बनाने की कोशिश
करेंगे एक ऐसी पिक्चर डेवलप करने की कोशिश
करेंगे ताकि हमें फर्द जो स्टेप्स हैं पेन
टेस्टिंग के वो परफॉर्म करने में इजी हो
जाए वनटी असेसमेंट है या एक्सप्लोइटेशन है
या आपको फर्द नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे जाने में
इजी हो जाए एंड नेटवर्क मैपिंग अलाउ यू
अलाउ अस टू गेट ए बेटर अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ
व्हाट वी आर डीलिंग विद इन टर्म्स ऑफ हाउ
मेनी सिस्टम एजिस्ट विद इन देर नेटवर्क
एंड देयर पोटेंशियल फंक्शनल रोल ओके और
ऐसा करके जो नेटवर्क नेटवर्क मैपिंग के
द्वारा ही हम पता कर सकते हैं कि कौन-कौन
से सिस्टम हमें नेटवर्क में एजिस्ट करते
हैं और वह सिस्टम कौन सा उस ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम रन कर रहा होगा उसका क्या रोल हो
सकता है व वेब सर्वर है या आपका एफटीपी है
एसएमटीपी है या ईमेल सर्वर है व्हाट एवर
वो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन हम सिर्फ नेटवर्क
मैपिंग के द्वारा ही फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं एंड व्हाट इज द ऑब्जेक्टिव ऑफ नेटवर्क
मैपिंग डिस्कवरी ऑफ लाइव होस्ट
आइडेंटिफिकेशन आइडेंटिफिकेशन
[संगीत]
फर्द आगे बढ़ने में या आपको प्रोब करने
में या फर्द इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में ओके
दिस इज द ऑब्जेक्टिव ऑफ नेटवर्क मैपिंग मे
बी एवरीवन गट क्लियर कि वई नेट नेटवर्क
मैपिंग इज सो इंपोर्टेंट फॉर अस एज ए
पेंटेस्टर
एवरीवन एवरीवन गट क्लियर
एवरीवन किसी का कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ
सकता
है तब तक मुझे 20 सेकंड दीजिए थोड़ा सा
मैं पानी पी लेता हूं
ओके अभी हम सीखते हैं कि एन मैप के बारे
में एन मैप क्या होता है नेटवर्क मैपर इट
इज एन ओपन सोर्स नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग टूल
यूज्ड फॉर डिस्कवरिंग होस्ट एंड सर्विसेस
ऑन ए कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क फाइंडिंग ओपन
पोर्ट्स एंड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस रन कर रही है कौन से
पोर्ट्स ओपन है और उसके अंदर जो बेसिक जो
डिफॉल्ट वलने बिलिटी है वह फाइंड आउट करने
के लिए आपको एक आईडिया देता है इट इज अ
पावरफुल टूल दैट हैज बिकम स्टैंडर्ड इन द
टूल टूल किट ऑफ सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल
नेटवर्क एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स एंड पेंटेस्टर्स
ओके अब जितने भी सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल्स
है या नेटवर्क एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स है या
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स है सबके लिए क्या है
एक स्टैंडर्ड टूल एक पावरफुल टूल बन है
उनकी टूल किट का हिस्सा बन गया है ओके इट
ऑफर्स ए रेंज ऑफ फीचर्स एंड फंक्शनालिस
दैट मेक इट ए वैल्युएबल टूल इन वेरियस
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी कांटेक्ट अभी इसके
फीचर्स और फंक्शन के कारण इसको काफी एक
वैल्युएबल एक इंपोर्टेंट टूल बनाता है ओके
एन मैप को जो इसके फीचर्स
है नाउ एनम फंटी की बात करते हैं तो जो
इसके फीचर्स ऑफ फंक्शन जो इंपोर्टेंट
फंक्शन फीचर्स है वो कौन से हैं होस्ट
डिस्कवरी पोर्ट स्कैनिंग सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फिंगर प्रिंटिंग
और सेम आईडेंटिफाइंग फिल्टरिंग एंड
सिक्योरिटी मेजर्स यह भी क्या है एक लेवल
पर फाइंड आउट करता है नाउ अभी बात करते
हैं होस्ट डिस्कवरी टेक्निक कि जब हम
होस्ट डिस्कवरी करते हैं किसी भी होस्ट के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हैं तो
कौन-कौन सी टेक्निक का यूज किया जाता है
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में फर्स्ट ऑफ
ऑल वी नीड टू हैव एन अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ सम
ऑफ द मो मोस्ट कॉमन एंड मोस्ट वाइडल यूज्ड
होस्ट डिस्कवरी टेक्निक एंड वी आल्सो टेक
अ लुक एट हाउ दिस हैज बीन डन हिस्टोरिकल
इन द कांटेक्ट ऑफ पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग और
ऑडिटिंग ए नेटवर्क आइर फॉर पर्पस ऑफ
परफॉर्मेंस परफॉर्मेंस और
सिक्योरिटी तो सबसे पहले हमें क्या है कि
यह पता होना चाहिए कि कौन-कौन सी मोस्ट
कॉमन टेक्निक है जिसकी हेल्प से हम होस्ट
डिस्कवरी परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं जो अवेलेबल
है जिनका यूज किया जाता है एज ए पेन
टेस्टर ओके नाउ होस्ट डिस्कवरी इन एथिकल
हैकिंग और पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग दिस इज
वेरी क्रुशल फेज टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एंड वल्नरेबल असेसमेंट
वेरियस ऑफ टेक्निक्स कैन बी एंप्लॉयड फॉर
होस्ट डिस्कवरी एंड द चॉइस ऑफ टेक्निक्स
डिपेंड्स ऑन द फैक्टर सच एज नेटवर्क
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक स्टेल्थ रिक्वायरमेंट्स
एंड गोल ऑफ द पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट बेसिकली
क्या है कि होस्ट डिस्कवरी सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट फेज होता है एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग का यह फाइंड आउट करने के लिए कि
कौन-कौन से होस्ट लाइव हैं ओके उसके बाद
ही हम फर्द क्या कर सकते हैं वल्नरेबल
असेसमेंट कर सकते हैं वल्नरेबल को फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हैं दूसरा क्या है जो होस्ट
डिस्कवरी की जो टेक्निक्स है जितनी भी
टेक्निक्स है वो कुछ फैक्टर्स पर डिपेंड
करती है जैसे कि नेटवर्क की
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक हैं या हमें
स्टेल्थ रिक्वायरमेंट है कि वहां पर अगर
कोई सिस्टम सर्विसेस लगी होंगी जैसे इन द
सें सिक्योरिटी सोल्यूशन लगे होंगे तो
उसके हिसाब से हमें इन टेक्निक को यूज
किया जाता है या जो आपकी पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग है उसका गोल क्या है क्या मोटो
है वन वी टॉक अबाउट होस्ट डिस्कवरी
टेक्निक्स अमंग द मोस्ट पॉपुलर टेक्निक्स
आर लिस्टेड बिलो अब जब हम होस्ट डिस्कवरी
टेक्निक की बात करें उनमें से कुछ पॉपुलर
टेक्निक्स है जो ज्यादातर यूज की जाती है
और आप भी यूज करेंगे उनको उनके बारे में
थोड़ी सी एक्सप्लेनेशन करूंगा उसके बाद
प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट प हम शिफ्ट
करेंगे ओके नाउ सबसे पहले जो टेक्निक होती
है आपकी पिंस वेबस होता है पिंस वेबस इज द
प्रोसेस ऑफ सेंडिंग आईसीएमपी इको
रिक्वेस्ट ट एसेंशियली अलाउ यू टू
यूटिलाइज आईसीएमपी प्रोटोकॉल टू सी इफ ए
होस्ट इज
ऑनलाइन वी कैन आल्सो परफॉर्म दिस ऑन द
एंटायस नेट यूजिंग पिंग यूटिलिटी ऑन
विंडोज मैक एंड नक् देखो सबसे पहले जो
टेक्निक्स है आपके पिंग स्वेप स्वीप्स
बोलते
जिसको जो आपके क्या करते हैं हर एक पीसी
के अंदर हर एक सर्वर के अंदर जितने भी
बड़े सिस्टम उनके अंदर एक पिंग यूटिलिटी
अवेलेबल हैती है हम क्या कर सकते हैं पिंग
कमांड का यूज करके किसी भी मशीन के बारे
में यह पता कर सकते हैं कि वह मशीन एक्टिव
है या नहीं है यह उसी फैसिलिटी को उसी
यूटिलिटी को यूज़ करते हैं करते हैं हम
ठीक है पिंग स्प्स के अंदर अब पिंग स्प्स
क्या करती है कि वह
आईसीएमपी जो प्रोटोकॉल है उसका यूज़ करती
है और आईसीएमपी प्रोटोकॉल क्या करता है
इको रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है और इको रिप्लाई
मिलता है तो अगर इको रिक्वेस्ट भेजेगा तो
अग उसका रिप्लाई मिलेगा तो तब इसका मतलब
क्या आपका होस्ट ऑनलाइन है इन सम केसेस यू
विल सी दैट पिंस और पिंग टेक्निक इफ यू
विल यूटिलाइज आईसीएमपी को रिक्वा डज नॉट
वर्क फॉर सम ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम सर्टेन केसेस
कुछ केसेस में क्या हो सकता है या तो फायर
वाल की वजह से या वहां पर फिल्टर की वजह
से जो पिंग स्वीप टेक्निक है आपकी काम
नहीं करती जहां पर क्या किया जाता है आपकी
आईसीएम प इको रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक कर दिया
जाता
है स्पेशली इन द केस ऑफ विंडोज फायर वाल
बिकॉज विंडोज फायरवॉल बाय डिफॉल्ट इज
कन्फर टू ब्लॉक इ को रिक्वेस्ट ओके तो खास
कर के जब आप विंडो मशीन को पिंग करोगे तो
वहां पर आपको कई बार क्या हो मैक्सिमम
टाइम में रिक्वेस्ट टाइम आउट देखने को
मिलेगा आईसीएमपी रिक्वेस्ट टाइम क्योंकि
वहां पर आपके जो आईसीएमपी रिक्वेस्ट है
उसको ब्लॉक कर दिया जाता है एज ए रिजल्ट
इफ यू आर ओनली रिलाई ऑन दिस
टेक्निक देन यू विल फाइंड योरसेल्फ मिसिंग
आउट ऑन विंडोज होस्ट दैट आर ऑनलाइन बट नॉट
रेस्पॉन्डिंग अगर आपके पास ओनली एक ही
टेक्निक का पता है कि होस्ट डिस्कवरी करने
के लिए होस्ट को फाइंड आउट करने के लिए कि
कौन सा होस्ट टिव है कौन सा एक्टिव नहीं
है तो इसका मतलब क्या है कि आप हो सकता है
कि खुद से जो विंडो होस्ट न जो ऑलरेडी
एक्टिव है ऑनलाइन है आप उसको फाइंड आउट
करने में इंपॉसिबल हो आप फाइंड आउट ना कर
पाओ क्योंकि आपके पास एक ही टेक्निक है
आपके पास मल्टीपल टेक्निक्स नहीं है और आप
ओनली वन टेक्निक टेक्निक पर डिपेंडेंट
करते हो जिसकी वजह से आप एक्चुअल होस्ट
फाइंड आउट करने में आप क्या करोगे कई बार
प्रॉब्लम फेस करोगे उसको फाइंड आउट नहीं
कर पाओगे या होस्ट को आप क्या करोगे के
मिस कर जाओगे ड्यूरिंग योर पेन टेस्टिंग
फेज तो इट इज वेरी इंपोर्टेंट टू नो जितने
भी आपके पास हो डिस्कवरी टेक्निक्स है
सारी आपको मालूम होनी
चाहिए जो सेकंड टेक्निक
है वो है आपका आर् स्कैनिंग दूसरी टेक्निक
का यूज किया जाता है आपका आर् स्कैनिंग
दिस प्रोसेस यूज द एड्रेस रेगुलेशन
प्रोटोकॉल रिक्वेस्ट टू आइडेंटिफिकेशन
होस्ट ओके अब आर् स्कैनिंग में क्या होता
है
कि यहां पर आपका जो आर् प है एड्रेस रेजोन
प्रोटोकॉल है उसका यूज किया जाता है होस्ट
को आइडेंटिफिकेशन
वायरलेस या फिजिकल तभी आपकी आ स्कैनिंग
पॉसिबल है वायरलेस के केस में नॉर्मली हम
सबसे पहले क्या करते हैं आ स्कैनिंग का
यूज करते हैं ओके टू परफॉर्म दिस स्कैनिंग
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर नीड टू बी कनेक्टेड टू
दैट पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क नाउ नेक्स्ट थर्ड
टेक्निक आपकी क्या है टीसीपी सिन पिंग इट
इवॉल्व सेंडिंग टीसीपी सिन पैकेट टू ए
स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट टू चेक इफ ए होस्ट इज
अलाइव इसको मैं एक्सप्लेन करूंगा सिन
पैकेट क्या होता है एसी के पैकेट क्या
होता है वाया है डायग्राम तो एक बार इसको
समझ लीजिए कि टेक्निक क्या है इसको मैं
एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा इट इवॉल्व टीसीपी सिन पैकेट टू अ
स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट टू चेक इफ ए होस्ट इज
अलाइव इफ द होस्ट इज लाइव इट रिस्पांस विद
ए टीसीपी सिन एसी के फ्लैग वंस वी रिसीव
दिस फ्लैग इट रेस्पों विद आर एसटी फ्लैग
ओके अब ये फ्लैग क्या होता है आई विल
एक्सप्लेन बेसिकली क्या करता है जब टीसीपी
सिन पिंक का आप यूज करते हो तो जो आपका जो
क्लाइंट है वो क्या करता है सिन पैकेट
भेजता है आपके सर्वर के पास आपका सर्वर
रिप्लाई में क्या करता है सिन एसी के
फ्लैग फ्लैग आपको भेजता है ठीक है रिप्लाई
करता है रिस्पांस में देन उसके बाद आप
क्या करते हो उसका रिस्पांस भेजने की बजाय
उस पर क्या करते हो
आप सॉरी सॉरी फॉर
दैट तो आप क्या करते हो वपस उसका
एक्नॉलेजमेंट भेजने के बजाय आप क्या करते
हो आर एसटी रिसेट पैकेट भेज देते हो मतलब
कनेक्शन क्लोज करने का पैकेट भेज देते हो
सिंपली तो इससे आपको क्या पता चलता है कि
आपका होस्ट अलाइव है अगर वहां से रिप्लाई
आता है देन यूडीपी पिंग करते हो फोर्थ
टेक्निक है इट इवॉल्व सेंडिंग यूडीपी
पैकेट टू ए स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट टू चेक इफ ए
होस्ट इज अलाइव दिस कैन बी इफेक्टिव फॉर
होस्ट दैट डू नॉट रिस्पॉन्ड टू आईसीएमपी
और टीसीपी प्रॉप्स अभी क्या करते हो आप
टीसीपी पैकेट भेजने के बजाय आप अपनी पिंग
रिक्वेस्ट में यूडीपी पैकेट को भेजते हो
किसी एक स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट पे या चेक करने
के लिए कि आपका होस्ट अलाइव है या नहीं है
ओके एक्टिव है या नहीं है या यह टेक्निक
तब यूजफुल है जहां पर आपके आईसीएमपी और
टीसीपी प्रोब को ब्लॉक किया जा रहा हो
यूजुअली इट इज यूटिलाइज फॉर एवरी
स्पेसिफिक केसेस वेरी स्पेसिफिक केसेस
एवरी सॉरी वेरी कुछ केसेस में ही इसको यूज
किया जाता है टीसीपी एसी के पिं इट इवोल्स
अभी टीसीपी एसी पे पिंग क्या करती है अभ
ये जो टीसीपी पैकेट में पिछली जो सिं
पैकेट में ये सिं प भेज देती है
डायरेक्टली क्या करेगा एसी के एक्नॉलेज
पैकेट भेज देगा आपके सर्वर के पास ठीक है
यह चेक करने के लिए आपका होस्ट अलाइव है
नहीं है अगर वहां पर रिस्पांस में आर एसटी
पैकेट मिलता है तो इसका मतलब आपका होस्ट
अलाइव है अगर वहां पर कोई भी रिस्पांस
नहीं मिलता है इसका मतलब आपका या तो वहां
पर कोई फिल्टर हो सकता है वहां पर कोई
फायर वाल हो सकती है या आपका सच में पोर्ट
है आपका एक्टिव नहीं
है लास्ट टेक्निक है सिन एसी के पिंग
पैकेट यहां पर क्या करता है जो टीसी पे
यहां पर जो आपका क्लाइंट है वो सीन एसी के
पैकेट भेजता आपके सर्वर के पास आपका सर्वर
अगर रिप्लाई में आर एसटी पैकेट भेजता है
तो इसका मतलब आपका होस्ट अलाइव है अगर व
पर कोई भी रिपस नहीं आता है तो वहा पर
फायर वाल भी हो सकती है या वह सच में
पैकेट नॉट एक्टिव भी हो सकता है तो जज ल
आर द टेक्नी ट कैन बी यूज ड्यूरिंग होस्ट
डिस्कवरी आ के बारे में मैं आपको बताऊंगा
कि आर् स्कैनिंग कैसे काम करती है आ
प्रोटोकॉल कैसे काम करता है डिटेल्स हम जब
हम पढ़ेंगे वाईफाई पेन टेस्टिंग हर एक
प्रोटोकॉल की अपने टाइम पर एक्सप्लेनेशन
है डोंट वरी ओके तो वाईफाई पैट टेस्टिंग
में हम सबसे ज्यादातर यूज करते हैं आर
स्कैनिंग का तो इसलिए वहां पर इसको बताया
जाएगा इसकी चिंता मत
कीजिए तो मे बी एवरीवन गट क्लियर
ओके तो मे बी वन क्वेश्चन कम्स इन योर
माइंड दैट व्हाई वी युड यूज मल्टीपल
टेक्निक्स एंड व्हाई दज ऑप्शंस आर अवेलेबल
यह सबका सवाल हो सकता है देखिए द चॉइस ऑफ
द बेस्ट होस्ट डिस्कवरी टेक्निक इन
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग डिपेंड्स ऑन द वेरियस
फैक्टर्स लाइक कैरेक्टरिस्टिक ऑफ द टारगेट
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स इन प्लेस
एंड गोल ऑफ द टेस्टिंग अभी मल्टीपल
टेक्निक बताने का तरीका यही है कि वह
डिपेंड करता है कि वहां पर फायरवॉल है या
नहीं है या आपके पास किस टाइप की
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है या उस पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग का क्या गोल है तो यह सारी चीजें
डिपेंड करती है कि कौन सी आप पर डिपेंड
करती है कि जिस टाइम पर जिस फेज में आप
फंसे हुए जिस पोजीशन में जिस कंडीशन में
जिस सिचुएशन में हो वहां पर आपके लिए कौन
सी बेस्ट और स्विचेबल टेक्निक है यह टोटली
आप पर डिपेंड करेगी मैं यह बता दूंगा यह
टेक्निक है यह टेक्निक नहीं य जिस सिचुएशन
में आप फसे हो उस सिचुएशन में कौन सी
टेक्निक बेस्ट रहेगी यह आपसे बेहतर कोई
नहीं
जानता मैप के बहुत सारे टूल्स है अल्टरनेट
टूल मार्केट में बहुत सारे हैं कि आप
नॉर्मली स्कैनिंग करने यूज करते हो लिस्ट
ऑफ टूल्स मिल जाएंगे उसका अल्टरनेट टूल
फाइंड आउट कर लेकिन सब बेस्ट है क्योंकि
एक बार इसकी वर्किंग प्रिंसिपल आप समझ
लोगे तो आपको लिस्ट अगर चाहो तो आप आप खुद
सेही पता कर सकते हो अदर वाइज आपको लिस्ट
कहीं पर मिल जाएगी मैं भी बता दूंगा कोई
इशू नहीं लेकिन फायदा नहीं है आपको बता
दूंगा खुद से कर सक लेकिन आप चाहोगे तो
मैं आपको लिस्ट प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा कोई इशू
नहीं
है तो सबको क्लियर है
एवरीवन प्लीज आंसर दीजिए
चलो अभी ए मैप को समझने के लिए जो मैंने
आपको बताया था जो अटैक्स है वो टेक्निक्स
थी बस उसका मैं एक ओवरव्यू दे देता हूं
डिटेल्स इंफॉर्मेशन इसमें रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है अगर डिटेल्स इंफॉर्मेशन तो एडवांस
कोर्सेस में वैसे आपको ओबवियसली मिल जाती
है देखिए यह क्लाइंट है आपका क्लाइंट सबसे
पहले क्या करता है सर्वर के पास सिन पैकेट
भेजता है रि और आपका जो सर्वर है व
रिस्पांस में क्या जाता है सिन एसी के
पैकेट भेजता है देन उसके बाद आपका क्या है
इसके रिप्लाई में आपका जो क्लाइंट है हम
है वो क्या करते हैं इसके रिप्लाई में एसी
के पैकेट भेजते हैं देन उसके बाद क्या है
आपका डाटा ट्रांसफर स्टार्ट होता है और जब
एक बार डाटा ट्रांसफर खत्म हो जाता है तो
उसके बाद हम फिन पैकेट भेजते हैं ये एक
नॉर्मल वर्किंग प्रिंसिपल है लेकिन क्या
होता है कि अभी हम इसी टेक्निक का यूज
करते हैं कि जो टीसीपी सीन पैकेट है उसमें
हम सीन पैकेट भेज देंगे एक्नॉलेजमेंट हमें
सीन एसी के मिलेगा और यहां पर हम क्या
करें एसी के पैकेट की बज आर एसटी पैकेट
भेजेंगे ओके कनेक्शन क्लोज देन एक टेक्निक
मैंने क्या बताई थी डायरेक्टली हम क्या
भेज द देंगे सीनसी की पैकेट भेज देंगे तो
यहां पर रिप्लाई में क्या मिलेगा हमारे
सर्वर से आर एसटी पैकेट कनेक्शन क्लोज अगर
रिप्लाई नहीं मिलता इसका मतलब यहां पर कोई
फायर वाल भी हो सकती है या फर्द फिल्टर भी
हो सकता है या सच में ये होस्ट डाउन है
ओके थर्ड मैंने आपको बताया था डायरेक्टली
एसी के पैकेट भेज दिया उस केस में क्या
होगा या तो यहां पर कोई रिस्पांस मिलेगा
या यहां पर रिस्पांस में क्या मिलेगा आर
एसटी पैकेट मिलेगा या यहां पर कुछ भी
रिस्पांस नहीं मिलेगा तो दिस इज द वे कि
ऐसे ये बेसिक फंक्शन टी ऐसे काम करती है
अब डिटेल में इससे ज्यादा डिटेल जाने की
जरूरत नहीं है ओके तो इतना ही समझो आपको
एन मैप समझने के
लिए नाउ अभी पिं स्वीप्स के बारे में जो
टेक्निक्स है उसके बारे में पढ़ेंगे उसको
प्रैक्टिकली करेंगे नाउ पिं स्विप इज ए
नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग टेक्निक यूज टू डिस्कवर
लाइव होस्ट फॉर एग्जांपल कंप्यूटर सर्वर्स
अदर डिवाइस विद इन स्पेसिफिक आईपी एड्रेस
रेंज ऑन ए नेटवर्क ओके द बेसिक आइडिया इज
टू से एन सीरीज ऑफ आईसीएमपी इको रिक्वेस्ट
मैसेज टू अ रेंज ऑफ आईपी एड्रेस एंड
ऑब्जर्व द रिस्पांस टू डिटरमाइंड विच
एड्रेस आर एक्टिव और रीचे बल ओके बेसिकली
मैं आपको समझा देता हूं कि पिं स्वीप में
क्या होता है यह आपकी पिंग यूटिलिटी कमांड
का यूज करता है इस आपके होस्ट को
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
अलाइव है जैसे आपने क्या ये सेकंड सर्वर
है इसको आपने भेजा आईसीएमपी इको रिक्वेस्ट
ठीक है आपको रिप्लाई में क्या है कोई भी
रिस्पांस नहीं मिल रहा इसका मतलब क्या है
या तो यहां पे फिल्टर है फायर वाल है या
यह होस्ट अलाइव नहीं है तो यही एक
टेक्निक्स है मतलब कि ये इस तरीके से क्या
आपका पिंग स्विप काम करता है पिंग स्विप
क्या करता है आईसीएमपी इको इको को यूज़
करता है आईसीएमपी प्रोटोकॉल को यूज करता
है इसी टेक्निक को अब हम क्या करते हैं
अपने पेन टेस्टिंग फेज में नॉर्मली ये
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए यूज़ करते हैं कि
आप का जो होस्ट है अलाइव है या नहीं है एक
तो ये टेक्निक है नाउ अभी प्रैक्टिकल डेमे
देखते हैं इसका कि जो पिं स् वेप्स है एन
मैप के थ्रू कैसे कर सकते हैं और दूसरा आप
पिन यूटिलिटी के थ्रू कैसे कर सकते हैं तो
मुझे एक मिनट का टाइम दीजिए तो मुझे अपनी
सारी मशीने ऑन करने दीजिए एक बार जितनी भी
मशीने आपके प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेट के
लिए ओके
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेट के लिए मैं यूज
करने वाला हूं पैरेट
ओस अगर आप भी चाहो तो खुद की पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग लैब सेटअप कर सकते हो आपको मैं
लिंक प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं यह रहा यह रहा
यहां पर आप क्या कर सकते हो मेटा फ्लोटेबल
3 फॉर वर्चुअल बॉक्स या एमवेयर दोनों लिंक
इसके अंदर है आप क्या कर स हो यहां से खुद
से सेट अप कर सकते हो विंडो विंडो मशीन भी
और नक्स मशीन भी और उसके बाद हम हमारे
मैक्सिमम जो बेसिक लेवल के जो पेंट जो
स्कैनिंग है या न्यूमरेशन है वह सारे इनके
थ्रू प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो इवन कुछ और भी
जो वलने बिलिटी बेस है सीटीएफ टाइप से आप
क्या कर सकते हो इन पर अपनी प्रैक्टिस कर
सकते हो टूल्स की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए इवन फर्द एक्सप्लोइटेशन के
लिए ओके तो मैं आपको ये लिंक प्रोवाइड कर
रहा हूं जिसको भी लैब सेटअप करनी है तो
स्टेप बाय स्टेप इस लिंक को फॉलो कर लीजिए
और सक्सेसफुली आप क्या कर सकते हो अपनी
लैब सेटअप कर सकते हो पेन टेस्टिंग लैब्स
जहा पर अपनी प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो
ओके
नाउ माय मशीन इज
ऑन अभी मैं बाकी दो मशीनों को और ऑन कर
देता हूं सो डट की
को मैं प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेट सही से
दिखा
सकूं लिंक शेयर कर दिया
मोहम्मद सबको मिल गया
लिंक देर ओनली 46 स्टूडेंट्स
हां आप कोई भी यूज कर सकते
हो सबको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है
क्लियर एवरीवन
ओ गया अबे गुड आपका पहले से सेटअप है तो
अच्छी बात है
भा एड पन टेस्टिंग कैसी चल रही है
आपकी अभी प्रैक्टिस कर रहे हो नहीं कर रहे
एंड्राइड एप्लीकेशन पेन टेस्टिंग
अच्छी बात
है कोई नहीं कोई नहीं कोई नहीं आपके पास
एक स्किल है ना तो उसको आप कभी भी यूज कर
सकते हो
न मिनट का टाइम दीजिए अ मशीने ऑन हो रही
है रेडी हो रही है उसके
बाद तो कुलदीप आपको अगर यह सब सीखना ना
पाइथन से ऑटोमेटिक सारी चीजें और खुद से
टूल बनाने है तो आपके लिए सबसे बेस्ट
कोर्स है डीसीएसपी प्रैक्टिकल डीसीएसपी
सिक्स मंथ डिप्लोमा उसको जवाइन कर लीजिए
अभी भी टाइम है सबसे बेस्ट कोर्स आपके
लिए ओके देखिए अभी मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कि
पिंग स्वीप कैसे काम करता है पिंग स्वीप्स
कैसे काम करता है जो पिंग यूटिलिटी है
कैसे काम करती है तो सब फॉर एग्जांपल मेरे
पास एक आईपी एड्रेस है मेरे एक सर्वर का
मेरे पास एक आईपी एड्रेस है फॉर एग्जांपल
कुछ भी हो सता जैसे मैं आपको अभी एग्जांपल
के र पर दिखा देता
हूं यह रहा टाइप आईपी एड्रेस पि कर रहा
एपल पि एंड
ड
0.04 104 फप मेरे विंडो मशीन का आईपी
एड्रेस है अभी मैं क्या कर रहा इसको पिन
कर रहा हूं अगर मैं इसको फर एपल इसको क्या
कर रहा हूं पिंग कर रहा हूं देखिए
अभी आपको एक लिंक बताया था कुलदीप मैंने
स्टार्टिंग के वीडियो में ही तो डिफ चैनल
डि फोनिक्स अकेडमी के जो वेबसाइट है उस पर
जाओगे तो वहां पर आप देख सकते हो हर एक
डिटेल्स वहां पर मेंशन है
अभी देखो य पर अभी तक कोई रिस्पांस नहीं आ
रहा मतलब कि क्योंकि मेरे पास विंडोज है
अब विंडोज में विंडो डिफेंडर काम करता है
बाय डिफॉल्ट जो विंडोज है वह क्या करती है
आईसीएमपी रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक करती है
आईसीएम रिक्वे क्या करती है ब्लॉक करती है
अभी देखो य पर कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा अगर मैं
आपको एक और चीज देखनी है तो मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं यह
रहा कंट्रोल सी प्लस
प्लस ना
दिस इज आवर वाय आर्क एंड आम यह भी जूम
करता हूं आपके
सामने नहीं नहीं फुल स्क्रीन तो नहीं
चाहिए था
मुझे अभी मैं इस पर क्लिक करता
हूं
ना अभी मैं अगर इसको अभी फिर से एक बार
स्टॉप एंड मैं पिंग यूटिलिटी दबा कंट्रोल
सी एंड देखो सारे पैकेट लॉस है फॉर
एग्जांपल पिंग मैंने यहां पर किया ओके
कंट्रोल सी पिंग करने से पहले एक काम कर
देते हैं यह
रहा ना
कंटिन्यू विदाउट सेविंग जैसे ही मैं क्या
करूंगा अभी पिंग स्टार्ट करूंगा पिं
देखना शायद अगर आप देखोगे तो यहां पर
आईसीएमपी पैकेट्स रहेंगे
देखिए रिक्वेस्ट है किसी भी रिक्वेस्ट का
आपके पास क्या नहीं आ रहा रिप्लाई नहीं
आया देखि सारे कहां से जा रहे 160 दि द
आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ माय मशीन नाउ द आईपी
एड्रेस ऑफ यर विंडोज मशीन बट यह सारी क्या
इको रिक्वेस्ट है इको पिंग रिक्वेस्ट बट
किसी का भी कोई भी रिप्लाई नहीं आ रहा ओके
किसी का भी कोई भी रिप्लाई नहीं आ रहा
इसका मतलब क्या यहां पर यह कह रहा है कि
आपका जो विंडोज मशीन है व एक्टिव नहीं है
लेकिन ऐसा नहीं है आपकी जो विंडोज मशीन है
व एक्टिव है लेकिन ड्यू टू फायरवॉल आपको
लगता है आपके पिंग स्प टेक्निक को लगता है
कि आपकी
मशीन वह क्या है एक्टिव नहीं देखि य पर जो
रिप्लाई आया किससे आया डेने अनरीचेबल अभ
देखिए मतलब देख सकते हो अभी मैं इसको
स्टॉप कर देता हूं ना उसके बाद कंट्रोल सी
करते हैं अभी दूसरी मशीन को मैं पिंग करता
हूं 192
168.0 222 और हिट एंटर करता हूं देखिए
यहां पर पिंग रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है आईसीएमपी
रिक्वेस्ट क्योंकि यहां पर जो फायरवॉल है
वो बंद है जो विंडोज मशीन है इसकी जो फायर
वाल है वह क्या है बंद है ओके तो इस पे
हमारा रिप्लाई आ रहा है फॉर एग्जांपल
कंट्रोल सी उसके बाद अगर फिर से मैं एक
काम करता हूं एक और विंडोज मशीन उसपे
फायरबॉल मेरा बंद है तो उसका भी उसको मैं
पिंग करता हूं तो अभी मैं नंबर ऑफ पैकेट
भेजता हूं ओनली
पिंग हाइन सी देन मैं ओनली सिक्स पैकेट
भेजूंगा
0.18
है 188 हिट देखिए इसका भी रिप्लाई आपको
मिल रहा है कौन सा है ये यह भी एक विंडोज
मशीन है सिक्स पैकेट के स एक भी पैकेट लॉस
नहीं हुआ लेकिन जब मैं खुद की मशीन को
टेस्ट कर रहा था जो मेरी खुद की जिससे मैं
आपको क्लास डिलीवर कर रहा हूं उसपे फायर
वाल एक्टिवेट है इसलिए वहां पर आपको कुछ
भी रिस्पांस नहीं आया तो इस तरीके से क्या
ये पिंग स्विप काम करता है अभी आप ही
बताइए अगर आपके पास एक ही टेक्निक होगी
मतलब आपको एक ही टेक्निक आती है कौन सी
पिंग स्विप टेक्निक है पिंग यूटिलिटी
द्वारा यह पता करना कि आपका होस्ट अलाइव
है या डेड है तो इस यहां पर तो फायर वाल
के कारण आपको पता ही नहीं चलेगा आप क्या
कर दोगे मिस कर दोगे इंपॉर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन
को एक और चीज होती है इसमें एक और होता है
क्लियर करता हूं आपके सामने स्क्रीन एक एफ
पिंग होता है ए पिंग को भी यूज कर सकते हो
और ए पिंग को क्या कर फॉर एपल पूरे सबनेट
को मैंने क्या करना स्कैन करना है पूरे
सबनेट प मुझे इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करनी
है सबनेट मास्क प तो मैं कैसे करूंगा फ ए
पिंग एपिंग के बारे में अगर जानोगे तो हान
आन हेल्प यह रहा एपिंग हाइन दज आर द ऑप्शन
और दिस इज द एपिंग य इसका काम भी क्या है
पिंग
करना हान 4 ओनली फॉर आईपीवी फ हाइन 6
आईपीवी सि एड्रेस बी अमाउंट ऑफ पिंग पैकेट
देन उसके बाद आप बात करोगे नेक्स्ट हम
नीचे चलते हैं यह
रहा यह रहा दे लट ऑफ ऑप्शन अब मैं क्या
करने वाला हूं कि मैं पूरे सबनेट मास को
स्कैन करना चाहता हूं तो कैसे करूंगा मैं
स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देता हूं एंड ए पिंग
देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा हाइन ए हान
ए का मतलब क्या है शो द टारगेट ट आर अलाइव
ओके देन उसके बाद हाइन जी मैं यूज करने
वाला हूं हाइन जी से मैं क्या करूंगा
टारगेट लिस्ट जनरेट करनी है इसका मतलब यह
है देन उसके बाद यूज कर रहा
192.168 जीरो फर सबनेट मास्क 24 देन उसके
बाद मैं क्या करने वाला हूं एक तरीका होता
क्योंकि देर लॉट ऑफ एरर्स तो उसको एरर को
हम क्या कर रीडायरेक्ट कर देंगे स्ल नल
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर लिस के अंदर एक तरीका
होता है तो मैं टू एरर को ओनली रीडायरेक्ट
कर देंगे हम किसके अंदर डेन डायरेक्टरी के
लिए डेव ब्लैक होल होता है य लिनेक्स का
हिट एंटर अब यहां पर देखना आपके सामने वो
सारी लिस्ट आ जाएगी जितने आईपी एड्रेस
इसके अंदर देखिए एक्टिव है जो भी है
103 160 159 181 188 225 और 22 दीज आर द
लिस्ट ऑफ आईपी एड्रेस दैट दोज आर एक्टिव
इन दिस पर्टिकुलर सबनेट मास्क ओके तो इस
तरीके से आप एपिंग का भी यूज़ कर सकते हो
किसी सबनेट मास्क के अंदर यह इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए कि कौन-कौन से
होस्ट एक्टिव हैं नाउ अब बात करते हैं n
मैप ए मैप के बारे में मैंने आपको बताया ए
मैप क्या होता है नेटवर्क मैपर होता है और
यह बाय डिफॉल्ट चा आपका काली
तो अभी हम सबसे पहले ए को कैसे यूज करें
अभी एक सिनेरियो आपके सामने क्लियर अभी
मैं आपको एक सिनेरियो दे रहा हूं तो उस
तरीके से आपको यूज करना है अभी मैं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं मिनि मैक्सिमाइज हो गया
ओके
मिनिमाइज देन उसके बाद हम चलते हैं
अभी ओके नाउ
नाउ
अभी लेट से यू हैव बीन असाइन टू परफॉर्म ए
पन टेस्ट ऑन ए पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क एट दिस
पॉइंट वी डोंट नो व्हाट इज ऑन दिस नेटवर्क
व्हाट डू वी डू देखो फॉर एग्जांपल अभी आप
एक ऐसे नेटवर्क जो ये नेटवर्क आपके सामने
दिखाई दे रहा है कि मैं डायरेक्टली
कनेक्टेड किससे हूं मेरे वाईफाई राउटर से
एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर मैं मेरी कंपनी ने
मुझे क्या कहा है कि एज ए पे आप एक काम
करना ये मेरा नेटवर्क का कंपनी का आप इस
पे पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करनी है ओके अब
मुझे जब इस पे पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करनी
है तो सबसे पहला काम क्या है मेरा क्योंकि
मेरे पास आई मेरे पास आईपी रेंज है या मैं
इससे कनेक्टेड हूं मेरे को आईपी भी नहीं
दिया ओनली इस बता दिया कि मेरे नेटवर्क प
क्या करना है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करना है
बस इतना ही आपको बताया तो ये क्या है आपकी
ब्लैक बॉक्स टेस्टिंग है ये कौन सी आपकी
ब्लैक्स ब्लैक बॉक्स टेंसस इसके अंदर मैं
आपको बता देता हूं एक विंडो सर्वर है एक
सर आपको इसका एक्सेस दिया हुआ है आप
वायरलेस कनेक्टेड हैं तो अभी आपको इसको
पेन टेस्ट करना एक रियल सिनेरियो दिया है
आपके सामने तो अभी आपको क्या करना है पेन
टेस्ट करने से पहले सबसे पहले क्या करोगे
आपको पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करने की
जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि यू आर द पार्ट ऑफ़
दिस नेटवर्क तो आपको क्या करना है अभी
यहां पर स्कैनिंग और एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म
करना है आपको क्या करना है स्कैनिंग एंड
एन्यूमरेशन पर परफॉर्म करना है ना तो आपके
पास यहां पर आईपी एड्रेस है ना कुछ है तो
आपको यह पता करना है कि यहां पर कितने
होस्ट अलाइव हैं कितने होस्ट डेड है किस
होस्ट पर कौन सी सर्विसेस रन कर रही है
किस पर कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रन कर रहा
है मतलब यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको फाइंड
आउट करनी है तो मैं कैसे करूंगा यह हमारा
टास्क है पूरे सेक्शन का और इसी लैब पर हम
काम करने वाले हैं इस पूरी लैब पे इसी
सिनेरियो प हम पूरे उसमें एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में काम करने वाले हैं
कैसे चलो एक बस फिर से देख लीजिए आप एक
मिनट के लिए कि इस टाइप का नेटवर्क है
जिसपे हम क्या करने वाले हैं
अभी एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एज ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर देख लीजिए एक
बार अ जो प्रैक्टिकल पर चलना है तो बता
दीजिए
चलो हम प्रैक्टिकली चलते हैं अभी बात करते
हैं ओनली होस्ट डिस्कवरी करेंगे हम आज और
इससे ज्यादा कुछ नहीं करेंगे
देखिए अभी मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं
देखिए अभी मुझे क्या करनी है एन की एन मैप
की हेल्प से होस्ट डिस्कवरी करनी है तो ए
मैप मैं रूट यूजर बन जाता हूं इसका कारण
बताऊंगा
सूडो एयू स्विच कर रहा हूं मैं मैं एक रूट
यूजर हूं अभी मैं चलो एक बार ए मैप के
बारे में जानते हैं कि ए मैप की हेल्प
फाइल में क्याक
है तो यह ए मैप की हेल्प फाइल है एम की
हेल्प फाइल में क्याक
देखिए इसका यूसेज है ए मैप स्कैन टाइप
ऑप्शंस टारगेट स्पेसिफिकेशन देखिए यहां पर
टारगेट स्पेसिफिक आ आईल यूज़ कर सकते हो
हान आईआर यूज़ कर सकते हो हान एएल होस्ट
डिस्कवरी करते वक्त दीज आर द होस्ट
डिस्कवरी ऑप्शंस एसएन पीएन पीएस दीज आर द
लिस्ट ऑफ होस्ट डिस्कवरी ऑप्शन स्कैन
टेक्निक के ये ऑप्शंस अवेलेबल है टूल के
अंदर एंड नाउ नाउ नाउ नाउ पोर्ट
स्पेसिफिकेशन एंड दीज आर लिस्ट ऑफ ऑप्शंस
हर एक ऑप्शंस के बारे में मैक्सिम ऑप्शंस
के बारे में हम क्या करेंगे डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं अभी मुझे टारगेट के बारे में कोई
भी इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं है मैं लेकिन अ जब मुझे टारगेट के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है तो मैं आईपी
एड्रेस की इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे पता करूंगा
बताइए कैसे पता करूंगा सभी
बताइए बताइए
बताइए प्लीज
बताइए
कैसे क्या मैं जो सिनेरियो दिया था मैंने
आपको ब्लैक बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग का कि मुझे
इस नेटवर्क पर पेन टेस्ट करनी है तो मैं
क्या करूंगा कैसे
करूंगा रिपीट यह है कि अभय प्रताप दिस वन
यह
रहा यह रहा यह नेटवर्क
है मुझे इस नेटवर्क का एक्सेस दिया गया है
अब मुझे इस नेटवर्क पर अभी होस्ट डिस्कवरी
करनी है लेकिन मुझे कुछ भी इ स मुझे इस
नेटवर्क पर कनेक्ट किया है तो मुझे सबसे
पहले इस पर होस्ट डिस्कवरी करनी है तो मैं
सबसे पहले कहां से स्टार्ट करूंगा कैसे
कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन ब्लाइंड हो ऐसे ही इस
डायग्राम की
तरह पिंग कैसे
करोगे आईपी तो दिया
नहीं ट्रैफिक एनालिसिस कैसे करोगे
अरे आईपी तो नहीं दिया
ना क्यों
करोगे अभी आपको पैस इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करने की जरूरत नहीं नहीं
है यस कुलदीप पूरे सबनेट को हम स्कैन
करेंगे लेकिन कैसे करेंगे यस मेरे पास एक
कमांड होती है आईपी
कॉन्फिन से कनेक्ट नेक्ड हूं इसका मतलब
मैं इन्हीं के नेटवर्क का पार्ट हूं तो
मुझे अपना आईपी एड्रेस तो पता है
ना देखिए इफ
कॉन्फिन फिग दिस इज माय आईपी एड्रेस
192.168 1660 यह मेरा नेट मास्क है ओके यह
मेरा नेट मास्क है तो मैं क्या करूंगा इस
पूरे नेटवर्क पर क्या कर
दूंगा ंग स्कैन करूंगा सबसे पहले मैं क्या
करूंगा पिंक स्कैन करूंगा पूरे नेटवर्क प
पिंक स्कैन करूंगा तो मैं अभी ए मैप की
हेल्प से करूंगा तो जब मुझे एन मैप की
हेल्प से पिं स्कैन करना होगा तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा उसके ऑप्शन होता है ए मैप हाइन एस
एन मैं एक ऑप्शन यूज करूंगा हान एस ए देन
192.168
42 फुल नेटवर्क मेंस अब हाइन एसन का मतलब
क्या होता आपका आपको ओनली पिन स्कैन करना
है पोर्ट स्कैनिंग नहीं है ओनली पिन स्कैन
करना है पिंग पिंग ओके अभी साथ के साथ मैं
क्या कर देता हूं
अभी यह रहा और इसको मैं रीस्टार्ट करता
हूं इसको
मैं कंटिन्यू विदाउट सेविंग कर देता हूं
कंटिन्यू विदाउट सेविंग ओके अभी के
लिए और यहां पर मैं भी क्या करता हूं यह
रहा और सिपली मैं जैसे इस पर एंटर करता
हूं एन मैप के र ट
एंटर
देखिए इसने क्या बताया एनफ स्कैन रिपोर्ट
192.168 अभी य इसने तो काम किया ही नहीं ट
इ वि
ट नाउ नाउ ना
फिर से देखिए अभी कैप्चर नहीं कर पाया
हमारा ट्रैफिक को नो इशू अभी देखिए यहां
पर
192.168 0.1
192.168 104 आईपी एड्रेस आपका एक्टिवेट है
111 आपका एक्टिवेट है 159 181 188 222 ये
सारे के सारे क्या है 225 और 160 दीज आर द
लिस्ट ऑफ आईपी एड्रेस व्हिच आर एक्टिव इन
दिस नेटवर्क मतलब अब हमारे पास इंफॉर्मेशन
है इस नेटवर्क के अंदर कितने होस्ट रन कर
रहे हैं कितने ये तो आपका क्या है राउटर
का एड्रेस है दिस इज योर एक दो तीन 4 पाच
छ और एक सात स एक आठ हमारे पास क्या है आठ
होस्ट अप है इसके अंदर नाइन हो ग टोटल
लेकिन आठ होस्ट इसके अंदर अप है ये
इंफॉर्मेशन हमने गदर कर ली कोई इशू नहीं
है अगर मैं इस
पर देखिए एक चीज आप नोटिस करोगे अभी नोटिस
नहीं की होगी लेकिन मैं आपको बता देता हूं
एक चीज नोटिस करोगे य रहा यह मैं आपके
सामने क्यों ओपन किया है सबसे इंपोर्टेंट
चीज है मैं आपके लिए बता देता हूं देखो
इसको स्टॉप करते हैं हम आर मैंने एंटर
किया य आरपी इसमें सर्च क्यों किया इसका
कारण है एक लॉजिक
है यह रहा एंड अगर हम इसको य सबसे ऊपर
देखिए यह रहा टीपी लिंक वीएम वेर र क्या
है र में मेरी मशीन है टीपी लिंक अभी य
सारे के सारे क्या आर प्रोटोकॉल का यूज कर
रहा है मैंने किया क्या मैंने कौन सी
कमांड यूज की थी एन फन एस ए पिंग स्कैन
मतलब आईसीएमपी इ को आईसीएमपी यूज करना
चाहिए था लेकिन इसने क्या यूज किया आर का
यूज किया यह आर प इसीने यूज किया है यह
इसने ही यूज किया है अगर नहीं पता हो तो
आपको यह इसी ने ही यूज किया है आर् दे आर
लॉट ऑफ आर् रिक्वेस्ट ओके दे आर लॉट ऑफ आर
रिक्वेस्ट
ओके नाउ अभी मैं एक चीज बता देता हूं
आपको इसको जूम करना है तो मैं आपको बता
देता हूं
ले चे एप की नी जदा जरूरत नहीं पड़ने वाली
आपको यह रहा ओके दे लट ऑफ आर पैकेट अभी
होता क्या है कि जब आप आपके लोकल नेटवर्क
से कनेक्टेड हो जैसे कि अभी हम कनेक्टेड
है किससे हैं इथरनेट के द्वारा या वाईफाई
के द्वारा सेम नेटवर्क से लोकल ने से
कनेक्टेड है तब आपका एप क्या करता है ना
आर्ट स्कैनिंग परफॉर्म करता है क्या करता
है एड्रेस रेजोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल का यूज
करता है और आर् पैकेट भेजता है क्या करने
के लिए होस्ट डिस्कवरी के लिए क्या करने
के लिए होस्ट डिस्कवरी करने के लिए आर
पैकेट को भेजता है ओके लेकिन मैंने इसलिए
क्यों बताया यह यह मैंने आपको इसलिए ऐसा
बताया सॉरी इसलिए इसलिए बताया आई एम सॉरी
फॉर ट आपको इसलिए बता रहा हूं मैं
कि
ताकि आप बाद में यह ना बोलो कि जब आप
प्रैक्टिकल परफॉर्म करोगे सर मैंने वायस
आर के थ्रू अपने ट्रैफिक को एनालाइज किया
है लेकिन आपने बताया था सर आईसीएमपी
रिक्वेस्ट को भेजता है लेकिन यह तो आर्
रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहा है ऐसा क्यों इसका कारण
यही है लोकल ट नेटवर्क में बाय डिफॉल्ट आर
स्पैनिंग का आर्क स्पैनिंग का स्कैनिंग का
यूज करता है ओके नाउ अभी देखिए अब अगला
सवाल यह कोई इशू है या कोई प्रॉब्लम है
जिसके बारे में हमें सोचना चाहिए देखिए ना
तो य कोई प्रॉब्लम है ना ही हमें इसके
बारे में सोचना चाहिए
क्योंकि अभी एन मैप को यूज करने के
साथ-साथ हमें उसके वर्किंग प्रिंसिपल का
भी पता होना चाहिए कैसे काम करता है ओके
सबसे बेस्ट चीज यही पता होनी चाहिए हमें
इसलिए मैंने आपको बताया ठीक है मैप को कि
आप डायरेक्टली आप कमांड रन करना ही ए
हमारी जिम्मेदारी नहीं है हमें यह भी पता
होना चाहिए पर्टिकुलर टूल कैसे काम कर रहा
है किस नेरियो में कैसे काम कर रहा है यह
चीज शायद मोस्टली लोगों को यहां पर नहीं
पता
होगा क्योंकि एनम को यूज करना और उसको
समझना दोनों ही इंपोर्टेंट चीज है और
दोनों अपने आप में एक मतलब रखते हैं कि
मैं एम को यूज कर रहा हूं एक मैं एनम को
समझ के यूज कर रहा हूं तो दोनों टर्म का
एक मतलब है तो मैं आपको क्या करहा हं एम
को समझा के यूज करना सिखा रहा हूं तो
दोनों का मतलब कवर हो रहा है ओके तो दिस
इज द वन वे अगर मुझे इसको ओवरराइड करना हो
नहीं मैं चाहता हूं कि जैसा मैंने आपको
पढ़ाया था कि नहीं आ स्कैनिंग की बजाय मैं
आईसीएमपी पैकेट को ही भेजूं अपने नेटवर्क
को स्कैन करने के लिए मुझे इससे कोई मतलब
नहीं है कि नहीं मुझे आप और मुझे आईसीएमपी
पैकेट को ही भेजना है तो उसके लिए आप
ऑप्शन यूज करते हो एम हान s ड ए 192 1680
1224 उसके बाद हाइन आप यूज करोगे कौन सा
हाइन हाइन हाइन सैंड हाइन आईपी इस फ्लैग
का यूज करोगे और जैसे एंटर करोगे अभी यह
जो पैकेट भेजेगा यह आईसीएमपी पैकेट ही
भेजेगा रदर देन आर पैकेट ओके अभी जो मैंने
आपको बताया था यह वैसे ही काम
करेगा हैसन का मतलब है पिन
स्कैन एसन का मतलब पिन स्कैन अभी देखिए
अभी इसने अपना रिजल्ट शो कर दिया और अभी
देखना
103 159 181
188 एंड 2 मतलब अभी कितने बताया इसने
होस्ट इज अप ए होस्ट ज अप मतलब जिस पर
फायर वल एक्टिवेट थी मे बी 104 इज मिसिंग
यस 104 इज मिसिंग क्योंकि जिसके ऊपर फायर
वाल थी उसने आईसीएमपी एक को ब्लॉक कर दिया
जिसकी वजह से एक होस्ट हमारा अभी डाउन दिख
रहा आपको ओके जिसकी वजह से हमारे पास एक
होस्ट की इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है
ओके अगर हम चाहे तो मल्टी आईपी एड्रेस को
भी एक साथ स्कैन कर सकते हैं कैसे ए मैप
हाइन एस ए देन उसके बाद जैसे कि मैं
मल्टीपल
192.168
0188 एंड स्पेस
192 ड
168.0
1 03 ओके नाउ हिट एंटर और हान आन
सेंड हाइन आईपी यह
रहा तो यह भी बता दिया कि दोनों होस्ट के
आपके अप है विद मैक एड्रेस ओके तो इस
तरीके से यहां पर आप रेंज भी स्पेसिफाई कर
सकते हो रेंज कैसे दे सकते हो एन मैप उसके
बाद ऑप्शन हाइन एस ए ओनली पिंग स्कैन
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग नहीं करता ओनली होस्ट
डिस्कवरी करेगा यह उसके बाद
192.168 मैं चाहता हूं कि मेरा 100 से
लेके डैश करना है न 66 तक स्कैन करें 100
से लेकर 166 तक स्कैन करें हिट एंटर यह
देखिए सब कुछ बताऊंगा
अंकित ओके अगर मुझे अब
फोर 67 आईपी एड्रेस को उसने स्कैन किया
जिसमें से फोर होस्ट क्या है आपके अप है
नाउ अब स्क्रीन को क्लियर करते हैं अगर
आपको क्या करना है ओनली पिंग स्कैन करना
है अभी पिंग स्कैन की खासियत क्या है कि
आप इसके साथ और भी ऑप्शंस यूज कर सकते हो
ओके और भी ऑप्शंस यूज कर सकते हो विद द
स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट पोर्ट मेंशन करके भी आप
कर सकते हो फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मुझे क्या
करना है टीसीपी सिन पैकेट स्कैन करना है
मुझे क्या करना है टीसीपी सिन पैकेट
स्कैनिंग करनी है कौन सी टीसीपी सीन पैकेट
स्कैनिंग उसके लिए मेरे पास ऑप्शन होता है
आपको अगर वायर शर्क में भी देखना तो मैं
आपको दिखा दूंगा साथ के साथ व आप खुद से
देख लीजिए एक बार आपके लिए सबसे बेस्ट
रहेगा आप उसको खुद से देख लीजिए ताकि आपको
समझ में आ जाए
चीजें तो उसके लिए मैं यूज करूंगा ए मैप
हाइन एस एन ओनली पिन स्कैन स्किप करना है
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग देन उसके बाद हाइन उसके
बाद होता आपका प और एस आपको टीसीपी सिन
स्कैन करना है आपको क्या करना है टीसीपी
सिन स्कन आपको जो बताया था मैंने 10 फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं
192.168 ड
0 डॉट मैं अभी ट्राई कर रहा हूं 22 पे ओके
एंड हिट एंटर यह देखिए होस्ट इज एक्टिव
बहुत ज्यादा जल्दी जल्दी इसने आप आपके
रिजल्ट को शो कर दिया अगर आप देखना चाहते
हो वाय स्प में वो भी देख सकते हो अगर मैं
पूरे सबनेट पे अगर ट्राई करता हूं तो वो
भी देख सकते हो जीरो उसके बाद
न 24 सॉरी ये
रहा नाइन होस्ट आर आप तो ये क्या कर रहा
है टीसीपी सिंस स्कैन ये क्या कर रहा है
कि पैरेट ओस भेज रहा है आपके सभी मशीनों
के पास सिन पैकेट रिप्लाई में आपको सिन
एसी के पैकेट मिल रहा है और उसके बाद ये
उनके रिस्पांस में भेज रहा आर एसटी पैकेट
और कनेक्शन क्लोज कर दे रहा है तो दिस इ द
अगर एक और तरीका है अगर मुझे ओनली अपने
स्कैनिंग को फास्ट करना है तो मैं एन मैप
हाइन एस ए उसके बाद हाइन पीएस अगर मैं
ओनली किसी एक
पोर्ट किसी अभी क्या करता है बाय डिफॉल्ट
क्या करता है ये कि जो आपका सिन स्कैन
आपका पोट 80 या पोट 443 प भेजते हैं
नॉर्मली ओके अभी मैं क्या कर हूं किसी
ओनली स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट प स्पेस व करना
चाहता हूं किसी पोर्ट नंबर भी चेंज कर
सकता हूं य के बाद मेंशन कर सकता हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल 2 पोर्ट नंबर मेंशन कर दिया 192
डॉट हो सकता है पोर्ट 8 प पोर्ट 443 प
ओनली उसी पोर्ट पर क्या किया सिन पैकेट को
ब्लॉक किया हो तो मैं अदर पोर्ट पर भी चेक
कर सकता हूं तो 192 168
डव नहीं
0.1 66 ओके ट एर देखिए
ओके इसने बता दिया कि नाउ द पोर्ट सीम्स
डाउन इ रिली अब बट ब्लॉकिंग द पिंग
रिक्वेस्ट हो ग ट्राई पीएन अभी हम इसको
पीएन यूज नहीं करेंगे चलो अभी मैं यूज
करता हूं 22 इस पर दिखा देते हैं हम होस्ट
जब ओके तो अगर मैं चाहूं तो मल्टीपल
पोर्ट्स भी मेंशन कर सकता हूं कैसे ए मैप
हाइन क्या कर सकता हूं पीएस अकेले इसको भी
यूज कर सकता हाइन एस एन चलो एसन कर रहा
हूं उसके
बाद दूसरे पोर्ट भी मेंशन कर सकता हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल पीएस देन उसके बाद पोर्ट
80 पोर्ट 443 पोर्ट ओनली 4 443 नहीं मैं
कर रहा हूं 3389 उसके बाद मैं ट्राई कर
रहा हूं कौन सा 445 मैं इन्हीं पोर्ट के
थ्रू स्कैनिंग करना चाहता हूं
192.168 मैं अभी जाता
हूं 104 पे हिट एंटर नाउ होस्ट इज अप मैक
एड्रेस आपके सामने देखने को मिल रहा है
अगर मैं न ये मेरा था टीसीपी सिन स्कैन
अगर मैं टीसीपी एसी के स्कैन करना चाहता
हूं तो वो भी मैं य कर सकता हूं कैसे एन
मैप
हाइन एस एन ओनली सिनस कैन हाइन प प के
मतलब क्या अगर आपको नहीं पता चल रहा कि
कैसे काम कर रहा है आपके सामने एक काम कर
देता
हूं एक और स्क्रीन ओपन कर देता हूं सो ट
की आपको दिख
जाए यह
रहा यह रहा अभी मैं क्या यूज करा
नाउ यह यूज किया था मैंने
अभी पीएस
टीसीपी सीन स्कन किया अभी टीसीपी सीन स्कन
अभी पी पी में क्या करूंगा टीसीपी एसी के
ओके टीसीपी एसी एसी के पैकेट में भेजूंगा
ओके तो ये रहा देखो
एन मैप हाइ
फन हाइ फन एस एन
हाइन पी ए देन उसके बाद
192.168
188 ट
एंटर नाउ होस्ट जज अप इस तरीके से आप इनको
भी यूज कर सकते
हो ओके आप इनको भी यूज कर सकते हो अगर मैं
ओनली इसके अंदर एकको पैकेट भेजना चाहता
हूं टीसी ओनली एकको पैकेट भी भेजना चाहता
हूं तो व भी मैं भेज सकता हूं पी की हेल्प
से एक आईसीएमपी पैकेट अगर आईसीएमपी पैकेट
भेजना चाहता तो पीई का भी यूज कर सकता हूं
मैं यह समझ में आ गया आपको एसन पिंग स्कैन
डिसेबल पोर्ट स्कैनिंग मैं यूज कर रहा हूं
हापन पीएस मैंने सन स्कैन किया पी एसी के
एसी के पैकेट पिन किया मैंने देन प यूज
करके यूडीपी स्कैन कर सकते हो पवाई पवाई
आप देखोगे तो यह
है एससीटीपी डिस्कवरी ओके नाउ उसके बाद पी
पिंग इको स्कन वो भी मैं कर सकता हूं कैसे
एम न ए ए ओनली फिर देन पी एंड फिर से अगर
मैं उसी पोस्ट पर ट्राई करता हूं
19216801 4 जो लास्ट टाइम अप था 104 अभी
डाउन दिखाएगा देखो होस्ट इज अप अभी अभी
एकको पैकेट का रिप्लाई ये भी कर रहा है
104 देखो कभी-कभी फायर ब्लॉक कर रही है
कभी-कभी अप कर दे रही है नाउ ये देखिए प
192 168 0104 ओके तो इस तरीके सारे रिजल्ट
को आप क्या कर सकते हो आप ओके ओके इसमें
एक काम करते
हो सेंड आईसीएमपी भेज है अभी आईपी करते
हैं नाउ अभी ये आपको क्या करेगा डाउन देगा
उससे पहले आर रिक्वेस्ट भेज दिया देखो
फर्स्ट सीम्स नाउन बट ब्लॉकिंग आवर पिंग
रिक्वेस्ट मतलब फायर वाल इसको ब्लॉक कर
रही है लास्ट में क्या होता है यहां पर
अगर मैंने हाइफ हाफ सड आईपी मेंशन नहीं
किया इसका मतलब क्या है कि यह
जो आर् स्कैनिंग के थ्रू इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
शो कर रहा था कि होस्ट आपका अभी आईसी क्या
कर रहा है ब्लॉक कर रहा है तो नॉर्मली जो
बेस्ट टेक्निक यूज की जाती है नॉर्मली अगर
आप देखोगे तो दो कमांड पर ज्यादा फोकस
करते हैं स्कैनिंग में एनम देख पूरी कमांड
आपको टाइप करता एम फन एस एन ड्यूरिंग
डिस्कवरी एस एन हाइ फन व वर्बोस हाइ फन टी
फटी फ मतलब आपके टाइम परफॉर्मेंस के लिए
देता है इसको मैं बताऊंगा आने वाली क्लास
में देन उसके बाद आप मेंशन करते हो टारगेट
आईपी टारगेट आईपी
192.168
0.04 यह हिट एंटर देखिए इस तरीके से एक य
यूज करते हो दूसरा आप नॉर्मली क्या यूज
करते एक बेस्ट वे है कौन सा यह
रहा एस एन एन मैप एस
एन दूसरी कमांड जो मोस्टली यूज की जाती है
आप ड्यूरिंग पैंटसिंग सर्टिफिकेट के दौरान
कर सकते हो पीई पी एस देन उसके बाद पोर्ट
नंबर मेंशन कर सकते हो 21
445 33
8080 और वर्बोस और ये सब सेम ट हंटर तो इस
तरीके से भी आप क्या कर सकते हो स्कैनिंग
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो दज आर टू वे जो
मोस्टली यूज किए जाते हैं जो पीएस होती है
टीसीपी सीन कना आपको स्टिल स्कैन भी बोलते
हैं बेसिकली स्टिल स्कन मग नॉर्मली क्या
होता है उसके लोग आपके फायरवॉल के अंदर
क्रिएट नहीं होते क्या करते है कि कंप्लीट
लॉ कैसे क्रिएट होता है जैसे थ्री वे हैंड
सेक जो आपका जो हैंड सेक है कंप्लीट हो
जाता तभी आपका जो लॉक्स है वो क्या होता
है फायर वाल के अंदर लॉक किया जाता है अब
जब आपका हैंड सेक या जो आपका जो कनेक्शन
कंप्लीट एब्लिश ही नहीं हो रहा तो इसलिए
उसको लग इसलिए उसको स्टिल स्कैन बोला जाता
है एस टी ई ए एल टी एच स्टिल स्कैन एक
सिक्योर स्कैन और द बेस्ट वे
ओके तो यह था आपका होस्ट डिस्कवरी नेक्स्ट
क्लास में हम पढ़ेंगे पोर्ट स्कैनिंग उसके
बाद हम पढ़ेंगे सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
उसके बाद हम पढ़ेंगे
ये आपके फायर वाल
डिटेक्शन एंड एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट ये सारी
चीजें पार्ट है आपके एन मैप का तो आई होप
कि सबको होस्ट डिस्कवरी विद दी हेल्प ऑफ
एन मैप आपको समझ में आ गया होगा तो जैसे
मैंने आपको सिनेरियो के साथ बताया था कि
जब इस सिनेरियो में आपको बताया था ये रहा
जब आपको आपकी कंपनी ने बोला कि इस मेरे इस
नेटवर्क को पेन टेस्ट कीजिए तो सबसे पहले
मुझे क्या करना था क्योंकि एक ब्लैक बॉक्स
पेन टेस्टिंग थी मेरे पास आईपी एड्रेस
नहीं था तो मैंने सबसे पहले क्या की होस्ट
डिस्कवरी कर ली अभी मैंने इस क्लास में
होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर ली कि इसमें कितने
होस्ट अप हैं कितने होस्ट लाइव हैं ये
इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे पास है और उनके आईपी
एड्रेस के साथ अभी मुझे फर्द क्या करना है
इसके ऊपर ये फाइंड आउट करना है किस मशीन
के ऊपर कौन से पोर्ट्स रनिंग है देन उसके
बाद फर्द एक्सप्लोइटेशन होता है तो फर्स्ट
स्टेप हमने सक्सेसफुली गेन कर लिया है
ड्यूरिंग पेन टेस्टिंग कि हां कि इस
नेटवर्क के अंदर कितनी मशीन अप है तो
एवरीवन गोट क्लियर सबको समझ में आ गया
होगा कि एमफ की हेल्प से आप कैसे
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते
हो स्टिल किसी का कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे
पूछ सकता है और मुझे नहीं लगता कि आज के
सेशन में किसी को डाउट होगा टीसीपी यूडीपी
या नेटवर्क मैपिंग से रिलेटेड या आपको
होस्ट डिस्कवरी की जो टेक्निक्स है इनसे
रिलेटेड मोस्टली सारी टेक्निक मैंने आपको
बता दी आपको फ्लैग शो कर दिए कि टीसी उसके
बाद आप चैट मैं आपको जब लास्ट हो जाए
कंप्लीट क्लास ओवर हो जाएगी आपको एक चीट
शट दे दूंगा उस चीट चट को आप फरदर रेफरेंस
के लिए सेव करके रखिए ड्यूरिंग योर पन
टेस्टिंग
जर्नी आई विल ट्राई कहीं पर मिलेगा तो
नेसस
का आई विल ट्राई
कुलदीप तो किसी कोई डाउट है क्लास में तो
प्लीज मुझसे पूछ लीजिए और मैं अपनी मशीन
को भी कर देता हूं पावर ऑफ एक मशीन
को
क्लोज सबने आज की क्लास में एंजॉय किया
अरे मैं आपसे कुछ पूछ रहा हूं मुझ तो
रिप्लाई कर दीजिए आपस में फाइटिंग करने के
लिए आप लोग और कोई काम नहीं है
मुझे तो बता
दीजिए आप लोग सेशन कैसे लगा
और मजा आया नहीं आया या बोरिंग
[संगीत]
था कल मेरी क्लास नहीं होगी अभी मेरी
क्लास नेक्स्ट थ्री टू फोर डेज क्लास नहीं
है हम मिलेंगे अगले तीन से चार दिन के बाद
क्योंकि मैं बिजी हूं मुझे कहीं पर जाना
है अर्जेंट काम है उसके बाद हम क्या
करेंगे नेक्स्ट थ्री टू फोर डेज के बाद
कंटिन्यू क्लास करेंगे अभी भी ट्राई
करेंगे हर थर्ड डे को या हर फोर थर्ड डे
मतलब एक दिन छोड़ के एक दिन हम क्लास ले
ले आई विल ट्राई ओके और आगे आगे क्लासेस
में सच में ऐसे ही मजा आने वाला है डोंट
स्किप द क्लास ओके डोंट स्किप आपने देख
लिया होगा कि हम किस अप्रोच में काम कर
रहे हैं और इसी तरीके से काम करेंगे आगे
भी
ओके वेय कैन गेट पीपीटी ओके तो आपको
पीपीटी मिलेंगी मैं
अभी सेम सेम करके
एक आईडी है कहां पर यह लिंकडन पर तो वहां
पर आपको पीपीटी मिल
जाएंगी अभी कुछ दिन मैं शायद आज अपलोड
नहीं कर पाऊंगा और प्रीवियस डे की बची हुई
है तो मुझे थोड़ा टाइम चाहिए तो प्लीज अभी
रिवाइज कर
ना कुलदीप पटेल हम जूम पर क्लास तभी लेंगे
जब कोई डाउट्स होंगे आपके डाउट ही नहीं
है जम पे क्लास तभी हो सकती है जब आपके
डाउट्स होंगे
अभी जूम पर हम क्लास मतलब कि जूम का सेशन
ओपन करेंगे और जिसमें सब यह बातें करेंगे
कि यह वह इधर उधर की बात है तो केलिए तो
सही नहीं है ना मेरे पास भी इतना टाइम
नहीं है यार आई एम वर्किंग प्रोफेशनल
मुझे आपके सेशन भी रेडी करने होते हैं और
भी मुझे बहुत सारी चीजें होती हैं तो आप
लोगों के लिए टाइम निकाल के मैं क्लास
डिलीवर करता
हूं तो आप लोगों को इतना सपोर्ट करना
चाहिए क
ओके फर्द कोई डाउट मुझसे पूछ ली अभी कोई
डाउट है तो नेक्स्ट डि बता दिए फिर हम
सेशन को एंड करते
हैं या शर आपके सारे प्रैक्टिकल सेशन ही
होंगे मोस्टली अभी थोड़े से फंडामेंटल्स
में कवर कर रहा हूं तो धीरे धीरे हम क्या
कर रहे हैं अभी प्रैक्टिकल पर ज्यादा फोकस
करेंगे अभी एन मैप का फुल प्रैक्टिकल्स है
और मेटा स्ट का प्रैक्टिकल्स है तो हम
फोकस करेंगे
अभी नमरे थोड़ा सा रहेगा नरेशन में कई चीज
आपके बारे में बताई जाएंगी जो आप लोगों ने
पहले से नहीं पता होंगी तो उसको थोड़ा सा
एक्सप्लेन करेंगे देन उसके बाद नरेशन
कंप्लीट करेंगे देन तो फिर हमारी कंटिन्यू
लैब्स रहेंगी उन परे हंट रहेगा हमारा
लैब्स प हम पन टेस्टिंग करेंगे अलग अलग
टाइप की वनबिल के ऊपर और देन धीरे धीरे हम
सेशन को अपने कल सिलेबस को कवर करेंगे और
एंड कर देंगे एक दिन नेक्स्ट टू थ्र मंथ
जितने भी हमारे पास
है उसके
बाद आप लोगों के पास एक नॉलेज इकट्ठी हो
जाएगी मे भी मैं मान के चलता हूं आप लोग
में से 50 टू 60 स्टूडेंट तो ऐसे जो
रेगुलर फॉलो करेंगे तो फिर
हम एडवांस में मिलेंगे डीसीएसपी अगर आप
लोगों को लगता कि हमारे पास एनफ नॉलेज
नहीं है तो आप लोगों को बाद में अगर थर्ड
बैच में कि फोर्थ बैच में जाना है तो फिर
हम डीसीएसपी में मिलेंगे नेक्स्ट फोर्थ
बैच में तो वहां पर एक साथ पढ़ेंगे फिर
ओके तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर मुझे
लगता नहीं आप लोगों के पास कोई डाउट होगा
तो थैंक यू बाय बाय अभी हम तीन या चार दिन
के बाद मिलेंगे सेशन में एंड गुड डे गुड
नाइट एंड एवरीवन टेक केयर बाय
बाय गुड नाइट